if you get on an airplane you're being
exposed to ionizing radiation so I took
my geiger counter on a flight I was like
panicking I had to shut it off because
it was like beeping like it sounded like
a bomb was going off and I was like
trying to figure out how to mute it
really quick oh my God I'm like sitting
on my seat and everyone around that bad
it's that bad yeah
hi everyone welcome back to another
episode of the trash taste podcast I'm
your boy Joey and I'm with the boys as
per usual and I'm with a special guest
introduce yourself I'm William Osman I'm
from the garbage flavor podcast
we have to suck off your eye cleaning
yeah
we've done two of those now have you
actually yeah
someone commented about how we were
performing much worse than you guys
okay we started watching you guys like
the same time you and uh uh trash taste
yeah yeah right and it's just funny I
feel like it was really funny to get
compared because it was not like
parents get mad at you yeah yeah versus
when your parents get disappointed in
you yeah it
is like your older brother yeah so well
we became our older brother first well
actually what I found funny was that you
actually went on and talked about anime
on your podcast
no we don't do that we didn't do on our
podcast so you guys you guys are kind of
like filling the gap of uh what we
didn't do you're surpassing the older
brother
yes I gotta say out of all the people on
YouTube the person I get people comment
the most like you look like a budget
William Osmond people what yeah people
always always why budget I don't know
maybe the evil British twin or something
I don't know that sounds more exciting
to be fair Connor's beard isn't as clean
as yours yeah you'll be it's so clean
yeah it is I don't have it I don't know
how that's insane
yeah so I don't I just trim damn you're
being so good that's why I'm the budget
how come you guys don't talk about anime
anymore
uh well there's only so much you can
talk about or yeah
I Won't Let You monetize yeah two of us
are like I guess anime YouTubers well
Joey's the next sound of a YouTuber at
this point and no I still watch it yeah
you still watch it I still watch it I
just don't talk about it you're not
funny Joey has Joey now watches it as a
hobby yeah actually I've actually gone
back to watching it as a hobby as
opposed to a job as opposed to because
it was a job for me for the longest time
and then after a while I'm just like I
kind of got bored of talking about anime
in video form but I still enjoy the
medium so it's like but see here's the
YouTuber dilemma is that if you don't
make a video on it then you didn't do it
yeah right so you know obviously my
audience clowns on me for that which is
you know understandable the people have
a field day with it but um yeah I don't
know I guess like I mean look because
the thing is we've always called
ourselves trash days from the beginning
right and we always called ourselves uh
as an anime podcast we've sold it as an
anime podcast but I don't think we the
intention was to talk about anime the
entire time yeah it's it's I never
wanted to talk about it yeah just in
general you guys have it's like every
now and then we'll like we'll throw it
in as a topic right right but it's not
like the main focus yeah I don't think
yeah I mean it's funny because even
though it's like an ongoing joke within
our own fan base on our own podcast that
we don't talk about anime I think it's
actually just really helped with our
branding and I definitely noticed this
when I went to LA and we met you know a
bunch of creators including you and
pretty much everyone we've met was just
like oh that's the link you're the anime
guy and you're like oh no yeah and so
like every guest we had in La was just
like yes I don't I don't really like
talk watch a lot of animes and we have
to somehow talk about it for two hours
I'm like yeah no
no we don't I think because like the
only real like anime episode we had was
probably with like Pro ZD yeah exactly
then other than that we maybe mentioned
it for like five minutes at a time but
do you want to talk that anime I
literally could not care less
wait about anime or about to talk about
anime uh I I okay
are you an anime fan William I kind of
what does that mean you've stepped into
the marshes
most anime is like garbage yeah I mean
that's probably why it's like yeah yeah
exactly do people actually get mad if
you say anime's garbage no we say it all
the time it's literally what do I mean
by garbage
and it will never again
um
uh it a lot of times is very cheap
what do you mean by that wait shape as
in like like they crank it out as
quickly as possible and so everything is
like they're they're sort of cherry
picking the most successful tropes and
strategies like instead of making a
really well fleshed out story yeah it's
just here's like uh dangling keys
I would argue American cartoons are also
I'm not saying anything this is not
about American Guard
you seen big mouth on Netflix this [ __ ]
is ugly
because I don't watch it I don't watch
any American card games there's
something about anime though that like I
think what I do like about it is there's
sort of the suspension of the real world
where it's yeah the the language barrier
makes it feel like something that's very
different from what you're regularly
consuming yeah definitely definitely
well I think one of the big issues with
anime is you're right A lot of it is the
same copy paste kind of story lines
character tropes and everything but when
you find that really really [ __ ]
special and good anime it's like to me
the reason I'm a man I'm an anime fan is
because it really is able to convey
these kinds of stories that you don't
really find in other mediums always like
really really hard right and I think
right now we're at a point where there's
so many anime being made that you're
right 90 of it is [ __ ] but there are
more and more like really really [ __ ]
great and amazing shows that you can
find on on a on a regular basis man this
is the most positive I've ever talked
about anime on this podcast
I I just I just realized well we never
introduced William yeah
because it means they should know who I
am oh true true true
um is there an anime you do like Ben
yeah
your favorite anime right I I just I
think that it's like if if I was to try
to get anybody a brother okay not the
first one yeah if I had to get anyone or
if I had to convince somebody to watch
something that's probably what I would
try to convince them to watch because
it's very he hasn't watched this yeah
it's like it feels like a very I don't
know it's just like a closer to kind of
Western media you know in a sense yeah
yeah I think in a lot of ways there's
some other shows you like just list off
something that you've watched
um I I watched part of Attack on Titan
it just sort of kind of I don't know I
don't like political stuff you don't
like political it just turns into like a
weird like governmental yeah season two
yeah
I want to watch something explode
fantasy yeah you just want to like turn
your brain yeah yeah I like Gundam
which condoms that's a whole Rabbit Hole
oh gee like I've watched part of the OG
the old old stuff can can be kind of
slow compared to like modern yeah it
feels like
um I mean there's like some of the more
mainstream stuff like you know Gundam
Wing Gundam seeds zero zero kind of
double O Gundam uh iron blooded orphans
I honestly can't remember the names of
anything yeah
in a way that would make it intuitive to
figure out which one came when yeah yeah
I mean I think the I think the reason
with Gundam is so confusing is that
there's just so many of them so it's
kind of like fate in us I I don't mean
to bring up fate but it's kind of like
that where there's just so much of
something that you don't even know kind
of like it's overwhelming again yeah
yeah the names don't really help you
figure out which one comes well because
it's not numerical no yeah yeah but
maybe they could have something like the
uh resurrection and then uh not the rest
okay there's some death Direction
burial okay so that comes before
Resurrection yeah yeah I was looking for
just a timeline I was like just give me
a timeline of like when each of them
came out because none of them even like
like time wise in their Universe yeah or
like the branches you know like the sort
of like the side right well this is when
the release date doesn't match up to the
oh my God the story order so you're like
oh this one came out but oh oh no okay
this was the last one it's like they're
not even as a monogatari fan I feel
called out it's just like why did you
guys choose to adapt this completely out
of order the thing about Gundam is that
I guess it's like the closest thing
anime has kind of like the MCU where
there is like there is like a timeline
but every story is basically
self-contained yeah but you know if you
have followed Gundam from this lineage
back right at the beginning then there
is characters that appear in like other
things it's like little Easter whole
political thing and they like they seem
to almost like take like an old
character and kind of bring them back as
like the new like the grandchild I am
surprised that you like Gundam
considering that you were just saying
you don't like political I don't I don't
don't like that part again
so that's like saying like I really like
Dune minus the political stuff you get
part way into Gundam and then I get
bored and stop watching it
I don't know if I can say that you're a
fan of Uganda formula one was all like
pit stops I guess with the racing wait
okay then what about so so you obviously
just like writings yeah have you watched
uh like gorilla gone
it's funny because you say you don't
like political stuff but you like giant
robots and I'm just like 90 of all giant
robot shows are police
okay you need like a drop of politics to
justify the robot fighting but if
there's an episode where there's no
robot fighting it's just politics
I'm out that's filler to me did you like
watch Code Geass do you do remember
cookie house did you like that I don't
remember but I think I watched all of it
there's a lot of politics in that but
there was also
any other shows uh Evangelion
[Music]
uh it's actually a good way to find
stuff just go through like find
something you like yeah and then go to
their Wikipedia and just dig through the
entire catalog
um I found a bunch you do something that
99 of anime fans don't do it you should
100 do that like go do like the director
or any any literally anybody that works
on these shows because it seems like
they all have like the same aspiration
so if they directed or if they did this
or that like they all have different
things they've worked on yeah they kind
of contributed to I mean I don't
understand why more anime fans do this
because this is a normal practice in
like say the movie industry or I I would
argue that they do do it for film
directors like you know if you watch a
soda Memorial movie or a shinkai Makoto
movie then you're just like oh I want to
see what other movies they made but I
feel they don't really do that when it
comes to TV animations I guess they're
my TV series TV series A lot of times is
adapting something new but yeah a lot of
directors in anime have such a unique
style and I guess some of the biggest
names have like the most unique style
like masaki yuasa yeah you might not
know his names but if you've seen his
work you know when you see one of his
words if you watch something like Ping
Pong the animation or the other man cry
baby or something like that but same
with hideakiana as well he's like such a
big name in the anime industry so from
Evangelion I got to something called
like the secret of Blue Water yeah
[Music]
we found a website because you can't you
like some of the stuff you literally
can't watch anywhere yeah yeah like you
can't pay for it you can't well
Evangelion you can watch it for like 20
years later yeah it's like free money it
only took like Netflix to acquire the
rise to Evangelion before you can stream
God knows how much money they paid for
that exactly right exactly yeah they
basically like you can like watching
their other you know work it's funny
that you can kind of
see them as an artist because they kind
of get stuck on the same idea oh yeah
yeah and so there was a lot of like very
sort of linear like very like very
parallel story lines
um in secret of blue water and
Evangelion of like this you know it's
just it's it's funny to see that they're
almost like like they've been working
towards this one story yeah across
multiple completely separate yeah it
works exactly what's the guy made Belle
called
the same movie over and over yeah yeah
yeah
he did the Digimon movie and was just
like I'm gonna make some awards which is
just the Digimon movie yeah again
they're like plagiarizing themselves
before it's just I don't know there's
also Mako shinkai now who I think after
doing your name yeah was just like
weather porn the movie Let's Do It Again
yo he's going like rad wimps on speed
dial it's like yo bro you you know I'm
gonna need you for the next soundtrack
bro yeah but the one I found that I was
the happiest to find I think like the
best one was we talked about a little
bit on our podcast is called Memories oh
my God ultimate
that is brilliant it is so good so good
like the the just the animation alone is
like I have never seen anything like
that magnetic Rose yes oh my God I'm
sorry you're the only one I know who's
seen it yeah I know oh my God I wish
they made [ __ ] like this yeah like I I
it makes me sad that that is not
something anybody wants to put money it
is basically Akira in space yes it's
[ __ ] insane it's so good you're an
anime fan yeah
[Music]
what I used to watch was anime
let me tell you about anime well I I
think probably one of the biggest
reasons why you don't enjoy modern anime
is it seems like you enjoy sci-fi giant
robots yeah uh two genres that really
are not thriving in the modern scene I
don't know why is sci-fi just like has
that has it just gone downhill in
general because I think it's just been
completely overridden right now by the
fantasy genre and then within the
fantasy genre mostly the isakai genre I
feel like every you know decade or two
it always flip-flops between the weather
fantasy or like space and futuristics oh
yeah of course right and right now in
like a giant DND boom and fantasy just
seems to be like the thing right now and
I'm sure in future it'll swap back to
space in like 10 or 20 years sure this
is like a scope creep everyone's trying
to worn out pizza yeah yeah we are
robots bigger are robots bigger or they
call it the power creep uh yeah yeah but
it's like in the whole genre itself yeah
each show has to have do the others yeah
well I mean when you when we had like
you're in Lagan which was literally you
know spoil a small small spoiler alert
although it doesn't really you know
change the enjoyment of the show uh when
they literally are [ __ ] using
Universe no uh galaxies I'm like where
there's there's nowhere to go they're
standing on Galaxy's there's nowhere to
[ __ ] go from here yeah and especially
like you look you look at something like
Dragon Ball super and they're like okay
Goku is the most powerful being in the
universe where can we go from here he's
the most powerful being in the
Multiverse okay but where can we go from
here well I don't I don't know now I
don't know there's a there's literally
no no way you can take that but I guess
one of the big things that I've missed
is a lot of just old school sci-fi shows
because I feel like a lot of I I feel
like those are some of my favorite types
of stories but it's so so rare nowadays
not even in anime just to find like a
good Sci-Fi story
um which is why I really really [ __ ]
enjoyed June yeah I was about to say
they've kind of had to resort to going
back to older media exactly and all the
franchises and kind of just like
re-imagining it for the modern audience
and again I think that's why like Dune
was so good is because like that's like
a story that was probably quite you know
abundant when it was first around like
in the 80s and 90s and stuff like that
but like yeah like now it's like other
than maybe like Star Wars like the new
the new song I don't care the three new
Star Wars trilogies other than that like
I can't really think of like a good
Sci-Fi show yeah that has come out
recently I think it's a lot of work to
come up with like a whole yeah
everything and then even more work to
try to tell a cohesive narrative
honestly you can just be like it's a
fantasy world right yeah you know
there's a guy selling bread and a guy
selling apples and everything's better
you don't have to think about the logic
of the world yeah you're like oh it's
how it used to be yeah you can like is
there a chart of like time versus sort
of sexualization of anime
I genuinely think that like that's
probably one of the tropes that kind of
just helps like one of the cheap shots
you can take to help retain people oh
yeah yeah just don't enjoy it at all in
shows I like hentai I'll watch hentai
well you know separate yeah you know
what but you know what's funny actually
the guy who invented the etchy genre in
manga and I didn't say the guy who
invented anime the guy the guy or
basically the guy who invented like the
the kind of perversion in anime is the
same guy who invented Mecca
so uh they're kind of go hand in hand
yeah I actually believe hideo yakiano
helped popularize the anime boob bounce
it was really literally called like the
gynax jiggle or some sort of the gynax
balance for a while yeah because one I
think it was like one of his earlier
Works what's what's his other Mecca work
that he's done not that's before
Evangelion die Buster die Buster I
believe that had like a famous shot with
like yeah he directed that yeah it's
like 120 frames per second
everyone's like all right this is the
future of Animation ladies and gentlemen
you've probably seen the high school the
Dead one as well so that she shoots a
gun and it like I don't think I've seen
that one oh and it goes through like
jiggling in the gun the bullet goes
between like oh like a gif or something
yeah it's a very famous yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah stupid it's so dumb but when
it's like that it's like okay now it's
so over the top where it's like it's
entertaining again in the middle ground
where you're like why why did you put
this in the [ __ ] like like fire force
like oh yeah that just had sexualization
in it for no [ __ ] reason I mean
there's a lot of shows that are like
that where it's like I thought I would
enjoy the show because it kind of dealt
in genres that I thought I would enjoy
and then it would just get side shafted
by this random etchy shot immature yeah
I'm like you didn't you didn't need that
you didn't need that to maintain my you
know attention for this show on Netflix
right now in the States they're like
it's like a Mech thing but there's like
a guy and a girl in the Mac right what
is it oh darling
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's like no one's gonna take you
seriously for the rest of the tour okay
I would argue that no one should take
darling in the Franks no no one took it
seriously yeah yeah not even the
creators of the show yeah seriously like
it's the moaning though moaning when
they like lock in like
I'm reloading my girl I remember when I
first watched darling in the Franks and
they revealed like the piloting system
in like episode two or three and I just
[ __ ] burst out laughing I'm like no
they did not do this they they didn't
have to though like why okay that's
trigger and they're like yeah they're
just trigger never take them so
seriously it's weird talking to someone
who obviously consumes has consumed like
a lot of old anime versus like I've
consumed I've seen like the progression
of I guess the fan service and
sexualization just kind of like like
having like going from there to there
yeah because it's uh darling in France
is made by Studio trigger and after
killing kill have you seen or heard of
kill the kill I think so is that like
the talking sure yeah yeah yeah yeah
like that that darling in the Franks
just felt like it stepped down in terms
of in terms of the fact that we chilled
out yeah yeah yeah yeah which is weird
to say that it kind of like I guess
desensitized a lot of anime fans because
yeah isn't it weird that we are openly
criticizing darling and the Franks for
being sexual but then when you go over
to kill the kill it's like yeah that
makes sense it depends on the show like
kill yourself never was meant to be
serious and neither was darling in the
Franks no yeah there's other shows where
you're trying to get me invested in this
world and characters in a very serious
way and should it get me to feel like
okay oh I'm so sympathetic with that
character and then they start groping
each other and then you're like what the
[ __ ] is that yeah what the [ __ ] was that
yeah killer kill was like it made it
made a little bit more sense yeah it did
did you did you ever watch uh seven
deadly sins yeah oh Jesus
it's so unnecessary yeah you'll just
start groping the woman randomly that's
just his personality trait and it's like
oh so this guy's he just molested he's
just a pervert Yeah and that's like his
thing yeah yeah and we're like ah he's
that's so funny and quirky he's like no
I hate this guy like if how many people
you know actually
we've asked that question yeah many
times we've written who the [ __ ] watches
that character and likes them if you
don't like that character yeah
yeah because like
there are melioda stands out there I
mean it's it's a very it was a very
popular anime and manga I don't know how
many people still stand for it fell off
so hard yeah really it was kind of like
fairy tale you know or that kind of
genre of show where it kind of just like
it got it had as a fan base and then it
kind of fell off when everyone started
clowning on it is that in the manga as
well that yeah version yeah yeah so it's
not just the show no no no okay yeah why
would they even add that that'd be even
more I do I don't know
he's kind of boring let's let's just
make him kind of a perv I think that
they would add it in if they weren't
willing to take it out yeah
well they a lot of the time it's it's
while it's not seen as weird to have
that in right and and two I think taking
it out would be just offensive right to
the author in a way it's like how could
you ruin his vision you know also also I
think the reason why Justin I know I
also just think like the reason why in
general I don't think we'll ever see the
The Disappearance I guess of that kind
of like perversion enemies because you
know Fort horny 14 15 year old boys are
gonna just keep coming yeah I mean they
keep spawning just come on over and over
just keep coming they just keep coming
they keep spawning and there's there's
always going to be an audience for that
kind of [ __ ] I mean there's the
population is shrinking so yeah that's
true that's true
I mean I mean come on like I remember
when I was a teenager and I first saw an
anime have kind of like this kind of fan
service and right when I was 14 I
thought to love her was like the
greatest thing ever created yeah I know
right and I'm just like that's just like
tits in our schools it makes sense and
you're like as a as a fellow 14 year old
I understand this but then you're like
there's a 40 year old man thinking about
this [ __ ] of me yeah you know yeah he's
like that's true what should I make for
the kids yeah I've got a bit of
perversion never heard anything like
yeah I like this when I was 40. I'm sure
the 14 year olds now would enjoy it like
even as like 20 20 years old 19 I was
like oh
[Music]
I mean that was the age where you're
just like oh I you you discovered that
hentai and PornHub
that was the moment that was the moment
you're the 19 and 20. what that was the
moment your brain switches that you're
just like I need more
will not suffice for me I'm trying to
think the first anime I ever watched
like I I feel like I have like this
Pokemon count yeah yeah I mean it's kind
of like that's Japanese I mean that was
like my first one yeah I didn't realize
it was even anime I thought it was yeah
I mean I think that was a lot of our
first anime uh it was either that or
like Dragon Ball Z which is a lot of
people's first anime especially who grew
up in the world
starts watching it you didn't like it
can I say it's crap or people get mad
what it's normal
I am very smart okay that's what it felt
like no yeah it was like
I thought it was really good the
consensus is that it's pretty good I
thought it was quite intelligent I got
through
I don't know maybe like six episodes or
something and I just it just it was like
it just felt like like how old are you
when you found it I feel like when you
go because yeah I feel like if you're
under 21 for some reason yeah it appeals
so that that sucks I think that's the
kind of people I want to be the main
character yeah yeah yeah well I mean
that's why I was in Shonen jump right
yeah right yeah right just for that
demographic like 80 year old like 17
year old me ate that [ __ ] up like yeah I
was like of course you like so much I
want to be this guy so bad
he gets Death Note dude he was the
original Giga chat bro he built like the
girls and and the abilities yeah he was
a chat and his dad loved him whoa that's
that's the insane
yeah I mean just thinking
I'm just like thinking like looking at
light now through Modern Eyes I'm like
damn light was a [ __ ] toxic as [ __ ]
person man he was science anime you
watch Doctor Stone no I saw
um oh God what's the time travel one uh
I like that a lot it's nice I mean
that's one of those like Classics I
started watching it years ago I think I
got like one episode in because it's
it's just I feel like every one of these
websites does a bad job like conveying
what it is it's hard to find reviews
that's one of those shows where I think
it's your best shoes click episode I I
stopped watching it though years ago so
I got an episode to be fair the first
stupid or slow or whatever yeah yeah
because I it's almost like there's not a
trustworthy source for me of knowing if
I'm gonna like something to be fair the
first 10 yeah
[Music]
the first 10 episodes are quite slow but
I think it's it's used to just build up
enough information and to get you
established enough where the second half
comes around you're just like oh [ __ ]
yeah it's also great in English the
English version is amazing I I just
watch everything have you watched
Psychopaths no okay
just just judging from what you've been
saying and judging from that's what kind
of shows you like you love Psychopaths
because it is a Sci-Fi doesn't have me
it doesn't have genre unfortunately sell
the viewers on it like picture to them I
think we've done this before but do it
again yeah
do the thing uh I mean it's a Sci-Fi uh
dystopian world that is very reminiscent
of a lot of classic Sci-fi stories uh
the entire world is based on a system
where you control People based on an
emotional score and there are points
where if you go beyond an emotional
score the system deems you as a threat
to society so they will automatically
lock you up or or if you get too
dangerous there's a gun that will shoot
you and you will literally explode right
you're literally too depressed yeah if
you literally get you're literally
disintegrates and what makes it so
interesting
exactly exactly is interesting and what
makes it so interesting is you know they
set up this world and the main villain
is basically someone who is so insane
that he breaks the system by being on a
level of insane that he's almost seen as
in in the system's eyes as the perfect
human being so that's that's that's kind
of like that's that's kind of the main
story of psychopaths
yeah yeah really really interesting and
it delves into some really interesting
ideas about if this Society really
existed what would happen to the people
in it how would they act how would it
how would they you know change and how
could you break a system like this yeah
it tackles moral issues I think really
really well to the point where it's like
it doesn't seem trophy in any way like
it actually gets you being like oh [ __ ]
if this was you know if I was born in a
situation like this what would I right I
was gonna say it's like situation based
like yeah here is a problem and then
someone has to deal with it yeah yeah
exactly yeah yeah so judging from now
you'd really really enjoy that because I
can't I can't think of like another
modern Sci-Fi show that's hooked to me
as much as Psychopaths has it's oh what
about Buck uh uh bulkarana have you seen
bulkarana oh yeah I love that one too
that's Mecca I always recommend that one
that's Mecca that doesn't have a whole
lot of politics to it yeah and it's also
psychological so you might like that one
as well
we've talked about that a few times like
[ __ ] up this is this is just this is
just what what anime wouldn't really
[ __ ] up I sat through darling in the
Franks
that's a different kind of fun that's
just that's not [ __ ] up that's just
what the [ __ ] yeah that's the trigger
going let's how can we make everything a
sexual innuendo okay let's let's just
make an entire show
um and just make it and make it like one
big section what happened to like
steering wheels and like joysticks I
thought mama my robots to have hand
control what are you gonna make a robot
that's controlled by a human yeah that's
the next video I don't know what we're
doing tomorrow
oh my God actually on that we should
probably explain what William does yeah
yeah what do you do on your YouTube
channel uh
when a random person asks you or a
family member who you don't really know
I I honestly genuinely don't know how to
explain it because I used to say like
science but we just we're doing a video
about oyster farming right you want the
science involved yeah but it's like not
it's the angle isn't I don't I don't
know yeah no the engineering doesn't
work the guy who's generally does
engineering which apparently you guys
are also weird yeah yeah
and you do YouTube are your parents
happy
I I got the degree so they were like
they were like all right if you [ __ ] up
you got the degree they didn't care that
you're throwing it in the trash right
now I paid for it oh they have no say
that
they were kind of like just because you
know I was doing YouTube while I was in
yeah that's definitely the 100 the right
way to do it oh yeah I kind of told them
I was like hey I think I'm not gonna do
engineering I'm gonna try this YouTube
thing out and they were like are you
gonna finish the degree I was like yeah
and they were like all right do whatever
you want yeah yeah I finished degree got
a job and then after about two and a
half no three three and a half years of
doing the job I was like I kind of hate
this right now kind of kind of want to
just do YouTube what's what's your
background same mechanical
mechanical engineering major and
electrical Miner oh okay mechanical yeah
I hated mechanical yeah I mean it's I
feel like people don't really know what
engineering is when they go into it and
they see they see someone like me who
like like I like building stuff yeah and
like ah engineering is like building
stuff and then you go to school and it's
like not building stuff like because I
think one time we spoke about on the
podcast how we didn't really use our
degrees but then it's kind of like it's
it's kind of
hard to really take that as like um like
a hole because obviously we're a very
isolated group of people right who
didn't use their degree saying oh it's
useless and it's really easy to say that
yeah I think it's complicated because
it's like it's not useless but okay who
do you what would you do I did uh
no I I did uh I.T like design Computing
so it's like even if you're not
doing it work you probably have done
stuff in regards to YouTube that
involved some of the its I mean I
learned how to video edits yeah yeah and
like audio engineering stuff like that
right so you learn skills outside of
actually getting a job as an engineer
because like if you get an engineering
degree like you're not ready to go work
as an engineer like you have to go
somewhere and you're going to cost like
that many money because that's like this
useless little blob that they try to
form you into like actually doing real
constructive work yeah and so going to
school is just kind of like you know
teaching you
some mads
and then some like just I don't know
maybe work ethic or problem solving I
didn't find like the mindset that it
taught was very helpful yeah I mean I
think like one of the reasons
engineering is such a good course just
in general is the problem-solving aspect
I mean that's that's an aspect everyone
will use in their lives and it's about
understanding a system and how to kind
of like find your way around the system
I mean regardless I do use my degree in
my job because that's basically YouTube
in a nutshell you know trying to figure
out the algorithm and how and how to
like make content that appeals to an
algorithm that's a problem that's a
problem yeah and you know there's some
people who get way more into the
analytical side of YouTube I noticed
I've talked to a lot of science
YouTubers and you guys are constantly in
the analytics tab there's a level that's
like good and a level that's bad yeah
and I think some of the science
YouTubers go way too far to the point
where they start kind of not quite
understanding like it's a little bit too
robotic and yeah it's like blame the
algorithm as opposed to maybe have a
more artistic or like empathetic
approach of like why would somebody be
emotionally invested whenever I'm doing
right right and it's just numbers
numbers numbers and it's like well
that's probably not a good road to go
down yeah I don't look at it at all
because it just stresses me out yeah I I
have stopped looking at it yeah I don't
look at it I don't really read comments
either I read like the top three or four
yeah yeah and I'm like nice yeah that's
nice yeah I try to check mine about a
week after the upload because at least
at that point like the honeymoon period
is gone and like it as like you look at
it rationally yeah I can as rationally
look at this as possible yeah like
that's a problem-solving perspective
right like exactly it's not going to
help to read a bunch of crap so I'm
going to figure out how can I use
people's feedback as constructively as
possible exactly exactly did you enjoy
doing your engineering degree while you
were there or I did I learned a lot like
I learned a lot about microprocessors
which is the electrical Miner because
it's like something about not doing
anything electrical it's it's like
witchcraft dude you can like if you know
how to use a computer that has that can
like talk to the outside world which is
is basically microprocessors modern
computers a little bit funky I mean you
still can't but you can do anything like
you can literally like the instant you
like you can write some code and it
turns a light on it's like oh my God
like I think that's what I didn't really
enjoy about doing just mechanical was
that you never really got that try try
to try something and get feedback it was
always like here is a concept of how uh
an aerofoil would react in this you
please use the aerofoil table which
tells you everything and use the number
so expensive to actually bring that into
the real world right mechanical stuff
and I understand that and it's just kind
of like ah damn it I kind of thought
we'd do stuff yeah but I mean I don't
know maybe school just sort of sucked we
didn't do stuff either but like that's
kind of I feel like every time I explain
anything to people the school is not
going to teach you to like pick up a
tool no right right like they're going
to do the analytical stuff yeah and for
electrical engineering maybe or computer
science like you can actually do things
because it's free it's cheap well free
it's cheap yeah mechanical stuff is like
oh you got to use the you know Mill or
3D printer or this and even if it's not
like actually expensive the sort of
timer required is like expensive that's
what I didn't like about electronic
electrical engineering which is we
didn't get to use any cool stuff you
know I'm talking as a triple E major
because uh I was always jealous of you
know mechanical engineers or aerospace
engineers because they always talk about
you know oh yeah I was in the Wind
Tunnel doing all this cool [ __ ] and I'm
like
it's too expensive yeah I was like
awesome yeah I was like I was in a
[ __ ] lab just like [ __ ] writing
code no my light turned on and that was
it and I'm like I'm like you guys are
doing all the cool [ __ ] it's been so
much time just doing CAD models and I
[ __ ] hate what is that it's like you
build the thing and like and I
understand why because it literally is
just engineering yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's you do that for everything but
yeah oh my God was this mind-numbing
doing it and I was bad at it I couldn't
visualize things in like a 3D space
that's hard it's really hard so I was
like this is this is miserable and yeah
there was some other stuff that I like I
I didn't do it because I was typically
doing YouTube
um so I I started doing YouTube about
second year of so in the UK we do three
years not four okay five and a half
normally it's like what a bachelor
before right it's supposed to before
yeah so in the UK it's three okay um so
second year in I started doing YouTube
so my free time is gone but there was
this thing that they did where every
single University and like um some of
them in the UK and some in Europe could
build a Formula One car oh yeah yeah
here they call fsae yeah and so
basically any anyone people from the
engineering people can just all come
together and build this car yeah and
they got to actually use all the tools
they got to build things your experience
with it oh that sounds fun and I was
like what did no one tell me about that
I would have like loved to have like
actually got hands-on experience you
still kind of sounds like my school a
little bit yeah where it's just it's
like very there's not a whole lot of
money I mean I don't think they're broke
but they just don't invest the money
into like creating you always hear MIT
MIT is like filled with clubs and
communities and stuff and that's like
it's so many smart talented people come
out of there because not the education
is better but the experiences yeah yeah
I think it's the moment you're my least
for me my lectures or classes which done
I was gone yeah there was no incentive
oh my God
on the campus and do anything else
because there was no other clubs the
only other like clubs that were even
related to my field were like I don't
know weird stuff that were just very
very Niche and yeah that I was like
smiling my only incentive was to just go
to the nearby uni bar and just get [ __ ]
would you have joined the club that was
like relevant to your field if you have
the option if there was a chance that we
could Hands-On do some stuff I would
gladly do it yeah but if I could use a
cad model and maybe actually get to
print something oh my God it would have
been awesome it would have been like oh
okay so I can make something CAD then
actually look at it and understand why
yeah I I built it like this yeah try
again but I understand that it's
expensive but like nowadays it's not and
so they probably do have them but like
even like relatively expensive like a
printer from you know five ten years ago
like you could still get something that
worked yeah that would be cheap you know
like the tree pass plywood they wouldn't
even like let us do like the laser cut
out
I just kind of wish there was more
chances to get more involved and and get
to whatever you learned kind of
visualize it or put something out there
so you can be like oh okay yeah like
something tangible yeah yeah yeah I
don't know let's just start connecting
the dots it's like oh if I do this work
I get this thing like I describe
everything as tools like math is a tool
yeah you don't have to enjoy using the
tool but you are like excited when you
use the tool to make something happen
exactly yeah like you know I I've used
calculus I think like once in my entire
life actually and it was literally for
like making a motor speed up and slow
down so I could like generate the
acceleration of it and it was like
it's like holy [ __ ] finally I used it
yeah exactly and I never did it again
and I'm okay with it but it's like you
know you could do it I know I could do
it yeah I understand it a little bit
better and it was like that felt so good
and it's like did I enjoy doing it like
I'm doing a bunch of stuff recently to
uh trying to build a CT scanner yeah you
like the like a 360 x-ray basically yeah
yeah and it's like I don't really like
doing math but there is nothing more
exciting than like writing some code
that has like the math you wrote kind of
works and it works and it's just like
I I feel like seeing that final product
and seeing that final effect makes it so
worth it because if everything's just
theoretical you're just like well this
is just [ __ ] numbers yeah there's no
return like if I wanted to do this I'd
be a mathematician you know yeah but
like my University had one cool project
which was like if you do Tripoli in
Bristol University I hope it's still a
thing in the third year we had this
thing called a buggy project where
um basically every you you know your
class will get split up into teams
so it was a group project but everyone
had to do like some part of it so yeah
everyone had to do some part of it and
we had like a buggy that we basically
had to program and amazed that the buggy
had to navigate a small car yeah yeah
like a like a small like a small RC car
kind of that kind of deal and it had to
like program to run itself around this
Maze and hit certain checkpoints and get
to the end in as efficient and
efficiently as efficient as possible and
that was the only fun thing I ever did
on the course because it was like a cool
thing that we all came together for and
we could actually see the final result
of our hard work instead of just you
know doing a model or doing you know
modeling some stuff on a computer or
some [ __ ] like that to work with other
people and it's about like if you can
trust these people and they do their
thing and I trust you know myself and my
teachers
exactly but like I feel like the problem
with I feel like that kind of thing
needs to be integrated in the course
because I know myself and if there was
some cool thing that you could have done
with your course that was extra
curricular activity in University I
wouldn't [ __ ] sign up for it I I know
I wouldn't have yeah maybe not in my
third year because I was already way to
invest in YouTube right yeah yeah
exactly but I think there are a lot of
people that would yeah oh definitely
there's a lot of people in that middle
ground who maybe do a specific course
and I think this happens a lot in
engineering where they're in that middle
group where they're like okay they
they're doing engineering they have an
interest in it but also there's nothing
really keeping them like super super
invested right yeah and if you could
just kind of capture that kind of middle
group people and push them towards hey
look you can you can actually make stuff
and make a difference and I think a lot
of people don't even know that they
would be interested in it yeah until you
sort of like if you open that door if
you sort of connect the dot between here
you made a cad model and then you
printed it and you're just like yeah oh
yeah yeah you know it's almost like it's
like stifling a kid who's interested in
something where it's like you know a kid
is oh I want to learn about this and the
parents like No And it's like for what
150 bucks you could have bought them
like a Lego set or something like that
and I would have like fired this
lifelong you know like learning
Obsession yeah like think of how cheap
that is you know like like a few tens of
dollars for the school like that it's an
investment yeah yeah but like
universities I mean they have lots of
money yeah they totally don't want to
they don't want to hire the people that
are required to get people excited about
stuff you know it's like oh we have a
machine shop but nobody can use the
tools because you're going to kill
yourself did you I don't know did you
have to do this well when they make you
buy like they made me buy I remember I
was so annoyed about this I was like
what they made and they wouldn't let you
buy a cheap version of it they made you
buy a book with like the table of all
the thermodynamic uh like constants of
every material and I I remember it was
like it was something like a hundred
dollars for this book and if you if you
dared bring not the book they recommend
they were like confiscated off just you
just brought back like a wave of memory
you're gonna have this
yeah University textbooks in general I
remember showing up on my first day I'm
like I'm ready to take on University I
got some spare change firstly you rock
up and they're like this is the
recommended they'll be like you have to
buy yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly
really these are the textbooks you're
going to need and then you look up the
prices and it's like minimum minimum uh
like like first edition it's uh 80
pounds or some [ __ ] like that yeah yeah
so that's one out of eight textbooks you
need I'm like see because we had that
list as well of like oh these are
textbooks you'll be using during your
first semester yeah but you don't need
if you don't want to yeah okay I won't
the end the third one I make one at
least for my exams if you didn't have
that book you literally couldn't do this
so they wouldn't let you that you had to
have that for the exam if you went into
the exam without it you have to remember
every constant for every material every
like grade of aluminum all right right
aluminum gross aluminum
um
you know they would be like different
like it would be like treated aluminum
yeah it would be like this is the
constant yeah this is insane like I
understand that you know like I just
think that why can't you please is that
something you're supposed to remember as
a name because no you can't remember the
comments well then why the [ __ ] because
they're [ __ ] well they want you to
get used to the idea of yeah okay if
you're using this material yeah using
like tungsten you don't need a hundred
dollar book to do it
that would be fine Google it yeah
I mean it probably was good and maybe
you'd reference it once every blue I'm
sure today there's probably like an app
specifically that just has like a list
this book was like editions I bet these
materials weren't changing that much I'm
sorry anyone doing any stuff like this
is gonna have the resources in the
actual industry like it's just you you
have someone who's gonna deal with
material someone is going to deal every
single CAD model yeah you would put in
the material and the type of material it
was and it would do it for you it
wouldn't even it wouldn't like you
wouldn't need to know the constant wow
you definitely like there are jobs where
you have to do this stuff but it's also
like most of the time
it's just like it's it's like you pay an
absurd amount of money yeah you go to
college or university or whatever and
then they they greet you with a hey
spend another thousand bucks yeah you
wanted to use to live on these dumb
books just because we refuse to make it
any easier for it which they could yeah
and it's just like I remember this big
pile of textbooks that like I had when I
finished my degree and 90 of them were
just untouched they were like a pristine
condition and I spent like [ __ ] 300
400 bucks getting this show on textbooks
I'm like why the [ __ ] did I spend that
amount of money I'm a broke college
student and you can't resell them yes
because there's additions yeah and
barely anything changes they rearrange
the question yeah yeah oh my God yeah
okay all right yeah I know it made me
feel bad
[Music]
I'm just realizing now like actual scam
it was like a legit scam yeah like you I
I can't believe it I would like strip
the security off the PDFs like I would
like spend hours and hours trying to
find ways to do that like finding some
python script that someone wrote and
then like and like throwing the PDF in
there like yeah I remember I bought one
all right I rented I think I bought it
from Barnes Noble yeah an ebook
then I've used this like python script I
found to like strip all the security off
oh [ __ ] and then I returned the book
back to Barnes and Noble and she had a
copy that I had a copy of the PDF that
was clean and easier to use did you send
it around everyone yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah what would this one be in no this
is years ago
I don't remember what book it was
that's good yeah I I really just like I
like doing like making stuff I think
it's kind of like art like I feel I
always used to laugh at like stem I mean
for the stem before like science yeah
and then steam where they like would
throw art into it and I'm like well art
doesn't belong in here and the more I
think about it the more it's like making
stuff is half art oh yeah because you
have to visualize yeah exactly kind of
have this this like like vision for it
that is quite difficult and it's a very
very difficult at times yeah and it's
like why else would you want to do
something if it wasn't art like if you
have to solve a problem that's more
engineering but if you want to do
something that is kind of artistic you
know like I used to try to make like
camera equipment and stuff so I had um
like a really crappy like camera slider
that was like skateboard wheels and PVC
pipes on like little uh
um what are those swively Wheels called
you know like early wheels or the ones
that you have on like office chairs yeah
yeah and so you could like you know
slide it back and forth get camera moves
and stuff just like making like
equipment that you couldn't afford to
buy that's cool and uh like I made a
thing
uh you know camera gimbals like the
stabilizer yeah like before any like the
cheap nice ones from DJI came out I
bought one from some kid who had like
screwed it up so I bought it for like
100 bucks because he had destroyed it
and he was just trying to like get some
of his money back so it's like
Craigslist bought it from him uh fixed
it up and then I I programmed a bunch of
stuff and added some Electronics so that
I could have this camera monitor
wirelessly like external to it and so
you could as you pivoted the monitor the
camera that someone else was holding
over here wouldn't move that's insane
um and it's like
I didn't need to do that like why did I
do that it's not because I'm trying to
solve an actual problem I had because
that kind of stuff just like oh this is
cool yeah I just thought it was cool and
so it's like you know that to me made me
realize I think that engineering like
science stuff is more art where it's
like I'm trying to like do things that I
think are cool and interesting and see
if I can solve these problems which is
like not far off from it's like painting
I mean do you guys do any kind of
Hardcore traditional art stuff have you
tried painting I have I think I have
negative art skills yeah I did a little
bit when I was young but I was never
good at it yeah well I mean I feel like
most people are bad yeah there's a
reason why I don't do it anymore yeah
right like anything yeah it's just like
no one's no one's a like I mean I'm sure
there's a prodigy but most people aren't
good it will beat them up yeah yeah you
know uh YouTube's an art form
making content right making content I
mean I think being able to visualize the
main content I make art
I think it takes a very creative mindset
to be able to visualize a flow and kind
of have that mind telling a story yeah
yeah that's hard people can't do that
normally you do have to you do need
practice Yeah the easier it looks like
your video was to make yeah about it
yeah the harder it was to know and a lot
of people exactly don't understand like
they think that we are much more
talented than we actually are like it's
a lot more head banging against the wall
to like get something to be don't say
that I was riding I mean I love you the
illusion is broken your videos are very
stressful like the Mr Beast one stress
me that I felt stressed watching that
one what's the Mr Beast one yeah you
want to explain it I know you go ahead
let's do a video
I so I got a I I got it it was such a
whole thing that I'm trying to like even
just compare this is like
yeah yes yeah
um
in I thought it was like a year ago they
asked if we wanted to make like a
subscriber or counter for them I thought
it was this and the uh the exploding
thing as well it's both oh okay so it
kind of started so I was like yeah like
this sounds fun like you know it'd be
like an introduction to their team and
be able to see how they do stuff yes
exactly mechanical clock that Rose notes
right oh so that was kind of the initial
conversation and then after that a
couple weeks later they're like hey
we're doing this good game thing and I
was like oh like okay like what do you
what do you want what do you need
um and it was it was a lot of time
and basically we needed to build some
sort of like squib system to make it
look like people were being shot yeah
right right oh okay yeah so they wanted
to replicate the a bunch of scenes from
the show yeah and in order to do that
you know what they do in Hollywood is
they'll have little explosives like
that's I think the actual squib terms
for the explosive charge that propels
the like the blood out yeah right but
they can use them for dirt and stuff so
you can bury them in dirt and cover them
during to get like bullet hits
so what you do on for budget is you kind
of use an air valve you get like a piece
of tube like a sprinkler valve basically
a little air tank out of PVC and you can
like project blood out that way but when
you're talking 500 people yeah like
there's nothing that exists that can do
that right and so we went through this
like nightmare process to essentially
theorize like completely synthesize from
scratch a device that could be
replicated 500 times in basically two
weeks so so yeah so once you found out
about this yeah when you found out about
a project was it two weeks before three
weeks
yeah so that's the exactly people think
three weeks they don't really understand
what that means yeah it would take a
week just to get the idea together yeah
and that's rushing yeah yeah so that was
week one week one was essentially what
people think you have three weeks for is
actually only one week so you have one
week to send something to a company to
have a prototype come back you can
remember in the video there's a lot of
problems with certain companies wouldn't
make certain things
right it was a disaster it was really
bad and it was probably like I don't
like I try to be very like kind of
passive and peaceful when I talk to
people about problems right I lost my
[ __ ] multiple times talking like I was
actually I I at one point I was talking
to someone on the phone I like I felt
bad I'm like I don't know if I'm going
too far or not like if I'm just being a
total [ __ ] right now but I was like I
like I literally said like I'm [ __ ]
you [ __ ] us and she was like language
and I was like what do you mean language
[ __ ] us like like I'm speaking English
like you're more serious like they
couldn't fulfill an order or something
they just didn't give a [ __ ]
I had sent them like like 10 grand it
was gonna be like 20 000 and we had sent
the first I think I could get that yeah
I mean if you if you're spending 10
grand yeah and it's like if if I sign up
for something and you tell me it may or
may not happen there's no guarantee it's
gonna cost this much money I'm like okay
you've warned me but when you say that
you're gonna get it done in like three
days and then nothing happens like how
am I not supposed to be pissed oh yeah
yeah you have it every right too yeah so
you had like you had one week of
planning and then two week of I guess
assembling 500. well because that was
like an app as well and all that and
that must have just yeah because it
seemed like crazy it was it was hands
down type two fun it was like one of the
worst experiences of my entire life one
font uh type one fun I think where it's
actually fun type two is where it's fun
after the fact okay
yeah that that explains so much there's
so many things I know in the moment I
hated it like that was awesome yeah is
there a type three fun I don't know
sadness so okay so you how did this
company [ __ ] you and then I remember in
the video there's like some uh some
family yeah own business there's some
small family business that's like really
understands the whole like circuit board
making World they basically intervened
and they helped to handle everything
because they understand how the whole
pipeline works that they understand how
to deal with these companies because it
turns out like half of these PCB
manufacturing companies are in Denver
Colorado right like they it's almost
like a that's the trip the board itself
yeah where they make the fiberglass
um so these guys don't make the
fiberglass because that's like a very
disgusting process and it's like very
yeah it's a whole chemical thing uh and
huge machines like huge huge huge
assembly lines and so these guys
essentially helped us to to intervene
and go to the company that was
originally making them still have them
make the fiberglass because that's the
hardest part to make then intercept them
take them to their small shop where they
would then assemble them which is the
whole secondary process like it it is
like it is such a convoluted process
that does not work well if you have not
enough time to do it like you have to
have almost double the time you need in
order for it to go yeah what was your
first question like why didn't you give
me more notice no I didn't ask them any
questions like I was very blunt with
them that's why I was worried some
people would get upset with the you know
Mr B's team for asking for something so
it's really crazy but it's like
they had this problem and I said I think
we can do it and I gave him I gave him a
price there's a lot of money and I was
like it's gonna cost an insane amount of
money right because everything we do is
like if you buy something for five
dollars you pay 80 to ship it overnight
yeah like everything is like balls to
the wall whatever is the most expensive
fastest guaranteed and I warned them
that you guys potentially gonna pay us
this money and we're not gonna deliver
you something are you okay with that and
they're like yeah and they said okay
well that seems like a very Mr Beast
thing dude it's just like money can
solve all problems
if you throw enough money at it it'll
fix it so sure I mean that that was like
the fairest most honest thing I could
tell them was like I'm not gonna be a
yes man or a no man I'm just gonna tell
you exactly how fuzzy it is yeah I want
to take the risk well as an engineer I I
hear like the three weeks delivery time
for the [ __ ] scale of this project
I'm like I would like to see this
project be attempted in Japan she's like
okay let me uh send the idea off for
approval you wait three weeks it takes
three months yeah
oh yeah we kind of missed the deadline
there yeah the boss is off you know yeah
[ __ ] another woman
I would wish to never do it again like
it was like three weeks like I am but it
was it was like the most stress I have
endured did they explain to you how they
got into this position in the first
place where they needed this project
delivered in three weeks it's just
it was like squid game hype gotta do it
now as quickly as possible right they
set the deadlines and it's like then you
look at the show or the episode of Mr
Beast and it's like everybody else who
did something similar right like the
giant sets yeah or the bridge or this
and yeah special effects and it's yeah
holy [ __ ] you guys like
it was that's crazy it was easy it
really was yeah how was it seeing the
final result after seeing like what you
got involved with and just seeing this
like I think this is the biggest project
that's been on YouTube that has that
comes to my mind other than other than
Jimmy also doing the Willy Wonka thing
it's all just Jimmy stuff at this point
you know like I mean right but I think
squid game was like the first one that
really sets the level of what he could
do and like him just like completely
leveling up his content I mean didn't
you say that that video cost him more
money than the entire production budget
of the TV series or something I think it
was it was it was very expensive it was
like two three million dollars right
yeah something like that and I think
that it was approaching or it was
comparable like it was in the same
ballpark like it wasn't exactly the same
I don't even think it was half yeah but
it was much closer than it should have
been for a YouTube video yeah yeah for a
single YouTube four or five million
right I think it was overall something
crazy I yeah I think something I can't
remember yeah what's the production
budget for the
no I did ask for more than they gave us
more but okay I because we had to spend
a bunch more money too yeah I was gonna
say I imagine that initially you
probably gave an estimate that was very
generous but even then it's like okay
well overnight shipping plus all the
yeah
and it was all it's also weird like
being on YouTube and asking somebody for
an insane amount of money because like
every if any other person came to me and
asked me about that I'm like I would
just say no like the only reason I even
entertain the idea is because it was Mr
B's I'm like okay well if anyone's gonna
be willing to pay what it's gonna cost
to do this yeah that makes sense yeah
it's like we had to like mobilize people
that had like day jobs at like Silicon
Valley Tech companies which like they
literally like had to just one of these
secret agents
how do you convince someone who works at
a tech company who like has trouble
getting time off to basically play hooky
wow sure most I mean it seemed like your
team was pretty good though yeah yeah
it's very funny I enjoyed your video
about it I seemed like it you made it
seem a lot more chill than I imagined it
was yeah yeah
what was it like on the filming day like
it was chaos so like the first day went
horribly wrong right they threw the
whole day away it's not in the I didn't
put this in the video oh really yeah and
I'll know we've got some sneak peek
information like there's a whole day
that that went wrong that they threw
away and they ended up paying all the
contestants like an additional I don't
even remember how much it was it was
like I think a thousand bucks each or
something Jesus but what went wrong in
the day it the pacing was messed up
because we had built a the squib system
and there was another company that was
supposed to do motion detection all
right and I had I had like I had warned
them I had tried very much to warn them
of like I don't think that it should be
done like this but it was too late
because it already paid these guys yeah
and
the way we like meshed the two systems
together was not good oh so just didn't
so the reason also the first day the
reason why I went back like that wasn't
used because the whole system was just
broken it was it was not broken but it
was a pacing issue that Jimmy wasn't
happy with because it felt like a show
not a competition if you wanted to be
like real time he wanted to be like oh
like you know green light go everyone
runs red light stops and then it's like
people start popping Yeah
well yeah there goes yeah so what was
happening was they would say green light
red light and then it's like this guy
that guy that guy that guy that guy and
it's like 30 seconds 45 seconds
it's like okay Papa and so it's like
it's the dysfunctional like it just
everyone's like not holding still trying
to hold still and they're saying oh
they're moving this and so it just you
know I mean they did everything really
quickly three weeks oh really but I
would argue one of those like 30 45
seconds of Silence be cut out of the
video anyway yeah but I think that Jimmy
likes it to be realistic realistic and
it also just kind of I don't know it
could be a weird energy if everyone is
sitting there yeah I can see why you'd I
guess uh yeah I mean that's gonna be an
expensive decision though to push it
back yeah so what was the solution in
there the solution was they basically
scrapped that entire other system that
they had 40 paid for oh wow then we we
were lucky because we had developed the
IOS app yeah which also wasn't even
supposed to be a part of the original
plan it just like that's a whole like
almost well it's one of my friends
friends like heard about the project and
he started just sort of making this it's
a fun just kind of for fun yeah and I
saw it and I was like yes I want a
friend that just makes iOS well it turns
out it's like like YouTube and Mr Beast
and money are a very good way to get
people excited like you you can pay
people to do something but you can't pay
them to get excited about it yeah that's
true that's true and that's like it's
you know people get kind of upset about
that sometimes of like oh I'm here to
work so that I can pay my bills and it's
like I get it but also if you are
excited about something the work tends
up you know ends up being oh yeah yeah
it fits everybody it's better if you
invested in it yeah it's better to be
passionate fixed all the problems so we
scaled the app from like six iPads to a
hundred iPhones and so literally we like
maxed out the developer account or we're
just like we spent an entire night just
programming iPhones over and over so
it's like USB you did all this in one
night a few hours yeah
so there were 500 iPhones because
everybody originally was wearing an
iPhone all the contestants yeah and that
was supposed to be the motion detection
but the problem was they started dying
yeah okay we were filming so long I'm
listening to this and I'm like yeah we
had an issue with our
um GoPros on bikes with uh because we
kind of just hoped that if you strap a
portable battery and it charges the
GoPro then it would work which worked
perfectly but there are some issues that
you just can't like predict yeah yeah
like when we were filming our drifting
special our GoPros were just overheat
because it was so hot yeah we just yeah
didn't have a solution so there was like
nothing you can do yeah I don't even
think they sell something that can
handle that yeah yeah yeah so just think
like hearing the story and just thinking
yeah we're just gonna like make a text
solution in like six hours and just kind
of hope that it doesn't that it works on
this three million dollar video I'm like
there's there's like part of me like all
of me is like like stress right now and
I wasn't even part of the part of this
project whether people just like
you know because obviously they want to
know when it's when it's going to work
where there are a lot of people being
like hey William when's it gonna be next
yeah so I I basically whoever like our
liaison there he's great yeah yeah
um and he gets it and he trusts me and I
trust him and so like there's really
good communication there where it's like
I'm I'm gonna be as literal as possible
like I'm not gonna be funky I'm not
gonna hide anything but there's a lot of
people who kind of are more TV minded
and I at that point I had such a short
temper
from all the stress yeah that I was like
the instant like somebody came like any
of their guys came to any of my guys and
they were asking stupid questions I
would just like I think they learned
like don't do not do not what kind of
things were they at just like oh like
when is it gonna be ready Wednesdays
like you guys like right now you ever
seen like videos like a raccoon in a
trash can yeah and they open the lid
it's like it's stuck and it can't go
anywhere so it's like it's really
aggressive it's like you've trapped it
yeah that was me yeah it was like I am
trapped in this this environment of
having to make this thing work I don't
know yeah [ __ ] if you have to wait 30
minutes like I don't give a [ __ ] how
much would it cost you like go away I
just I just realized is it ready yet is
one of the most asinine questions to ask
it's like if it was radio I would
[ __ ] tell you it's the equivalent to
are We There Yet yeah you know or it's
like why are you asking that Christmas
what'd you do it again yeah
I I would say no unless I the idea was
exciting the idea was exciting and it
would it would have to be a little bit
more time like literally one extra week
yeah it would have made a huge
difference because there's just
something about like if you have too
much time you'll drag it out and if you
have too little time it's going to be a
nightmare like there's a sweet spot
where like you can start panicking at
five weeks and you'll get it done right
yeah if you have five years like why are
you gonna Rush yeah that's true just
like hearing the story it actually like
gives me anxiety it's like it's like you
know like you know that feeling where
you've gotta you've got a deadline the
next day and you haven't started your
dissertation until the night before it
feels like that but just for like three
weeks constantly like the crushing
feeling of knowing it can't be done yeah
I was at home I think for like only a
couple days that whole three weeks yeah
I think 11 flights where will you go I
flew up to San Francisco to Texas
Colorado North Carolina yeah yeah I
think I would actually get like like
nightmares just like that yeah like I
just wake up in the cold swear I was
like Jimmy's got a request I was
probably sleeping like four to six hours
every night which is not a lot like
every night it was it was rough I mean
like you guys make you know like bigger
videos like when you have a goal to go
do something like imagine like when
you're doing a video failing is okay for
the most part because you know if I'm
trying to do this and you know oh like
like your car breaks down or something
like that's part of the content but
there's something horrible about about
engineering where not just engineering
but engineering from like a practical
perspective not a YouTube perspective
where it's like 500 of these have to
work yeah it's not like my video where I
can make it work and if it stops working
I stop filming and I fix it and then I
do like these have to work yeah they
have to work yeah
it gets the point where you involved in
a project like this and it's very
different from just making your own
video because you realize there's so
many different moving Parts whereas if
your moving part doesn't work that then
that affects everything everyone else's
things yeah but they've been working on
and it's just oh and then you're like I
know how much money they're spending on
this yeah yeah and I'm like I'm not
gonna be the guy that ruins it yeah this
is my senior design project in college
was this uh UAV it was like an airplane
that we were supposed to fly and you're
supposed to look at Targets on the
ground and yeah yeah and there was like
60 people on the team there's way too
many people right
um so I built this whole like image
recognition system and it was supposed
to like I never programmed it because
long story is short turns out if the
plane doesn't fly because the team that
was supposed to make it Fly Just do a
good job then what's the point of all
the work
you know so it's like I'm not going to
be the guy yeah that doesn't allow this
video to take off like exactly it's not
gonna be me because we do we know
actually how much money you spend on
that video yes that sounds right yeah
3.5 million so we weren't even right it
was 3.5 I thought it was like 2.5 yeah
how much was his actual squid game
it's a different thing entirely why are
you getting it I don't know you know you
know how sometimes you have a nightmare
where you like you go to school and
you're naked or some [ __ ] or you like
haven't prepared for this homework do
you think like Jimmy's team just like
wakes up and just like just wakes up to
a fake phone call with Jimmy or
something having like a request you're
fired
so I actually we I filmed a video with
him so we did the subscriber counter um
which I don't think has been published
anywhere I'm not I'm not making a video
but I'm not doing another project from
like I was just like nope just gonna do
this thing yeah I'm not gonna yeah yeah
um but I asked him if I could like make
a video where I live with him for 24
hours
and he said yes oh wow okay I got to
spend a full 24 hours like going through
exactly what they do every single day
right and got to sleep in his uh
uh and it's definitely like there's a
lot of like chaperoning where it's like
you gotta be here you got to be here
like his phone's always going off like
people are always like asking him for
feedback about stuff and it's like it's
a lot like I definitely you know it's a
it's a whole thing you get anxiety just
being near it yeah kind of I think at
the end of the day I would not trade
places with him no no way no way like
absolutely not I don't so what did you
do in this one 24 hours then just
everything you did when is it coming out
the video I I don't do it or something I
noticed it when I start to you I'm like
yeah editing it takes a while it does
yeah she's usually you or anything right
and everything yeah we've been I've been
having somebody help me which has been
helping a lot
um like I think that I just
I don't know I mean I don't know how you
guys had it but like for me it's like I
try to like figure out like the best way
to make it work yeah I mean they don't
hate it
like I used to and then I found why
would I why would I do the opposite yeah
I used to not oh see because I was like
I am a bad editor yeah and there are
people who are very good at it I'm a bad
editor I'm just getting married
until it makes sense yeah yeah I mean I
still edit everything I do and it's more
of just I think I've just realized that
90 of this work was like there there are
some things I really value in terms of
my editing in terms of like how it
portrays my personality and everything
like that and I realized that was only
about 10 of the video maybe so I can get
someone else to do the stuff that I
hated doing which is just cutting down
this timeline and getting this uh
getting this into the timeline and
finding the presents yeah and then I
could do the fun Parts yeah so sorry
Alan
that's what I'm trying to do but like
one of the things we've been thinking
about a lot recently is is like why are
people watching certain things like what
is it about a video that gets people
like why do people spend time watching
YouTube videos yeah you know and so it's
like trying to answer well well you know
so it's like you know I never really
understood twitch for the longest time
and then I realized like oh my God I
drive to school every single day
listening to like a radio talk show yeah
that's exactly the same thing like
literally exactly the same thing yeah
yeah and so now you can just see the
face right now and I think that when I
like try to think of why I watch videos
it's like I like stories I like sort of
interesting you know facts I like like
motivation and purpose and so I've been
trying to like figure out how do you
become like how do you make the audience
understand that motivation and purpose
before getting into a video like why are
you doing what you're doing you know
yeah why should they stay to the end
yeah how do you get like what's your
creative process in terms of like making
ideas then because it feels like your
videos now are so varied in terms of
ideas is that like you just like come up
with a random idea was it like an entire
process to be like this would be an
interesting story to tell so sometimes
it's
this would be an interesting title
thumbnail like I think this title
thumbnail would work well is that
something Mark Rober yeah taught me a
long time ago of like if I can't imagine
the title thumbnail I won't film the
video we've said this as well yeah and
that's can be really frustrating
as I guess like the artist side of
things of like but I want to do this
thing
how do you tell people how do you
convince people to watch a thing you
know and they'll you know everyone will
tell you like oh that sounds interesting
and it's like
it's easy to say but actually you know
clicking on is a different story yeah
and so that's that's something where you
know like what what tends to work well
if anybody's trying to do YouTube is
what is an actual problem you actually
have that you can fix
yeah that works really well like here's
an issue in my life that will most
likely relate to other people yeah yeah
and that's going to do two things like
it's going to help establish why you're
doing it and it's going to tell them why
they should get to the end of it yeah do
you need to go to the doctor for your CT
scanner are you putting it off
I actually spent days like I was
planning on doing an x-ray video before
I went to the hospital right did that
that video scared a lot of people there
right yeah because they were like extra
yeah it's I mean it's not good but it's
not that bad
okay hold on
right what do you mean I'm not I'm not a
radiation expert at all
so I
I'm the right guy for the job x-rays are
ionizing radiation which means that they
can damage your cells which can cause
cancer so statistically speaking if
you're exposed to more ionizing
radiation you will have a higher chance
of getting cancer yeah if you get on an
airplane you're being exposed to
ionizing radiation if you work on an
airplane you are regularly being exposed
to ionizing radiation an x-ray is pretty
much in the same ballpark as taking
flights so if you work as like a
stewardess or a pilot you are being
exposed to way way way way more
radiation than whatever that video was I
know that yeah yeah which is a little
terrible what's going on a lot of
flights
of course I took my geiger counter on a
flight because I wanted to like No And I
was like panicking I had to shut it off
because it was like beeping like yeah
yes it was going ape [ __ ] and I was like
it sounded like a bomb was going off and
I was like trying to figure out how to
mute it really quick oh my God I'm like
sitting on my seat and everyone was that
bad it's that bad yeah
literally sometimes there's some
knowledge that you don't need to know I
think that was like one of it you know
this episode is sponsored by PC
specialist get ready for the next
Generation in PC gaming with PC
Specialists get ready to Market from day
one with the latest component launches
PC Specialists are one of the leading
custom PC manufacturers in Europe
specializing in gaming PCs laptops
workstations and a whole lot more my
first good computer was actually PC
specialist I got about 10 11 years ago
and it never let me down I loved it if
you have a focus on building high
performance systems for gamers
enthusiasts content creators and
professionals like this man right here
definitely not a professional luckily
they're easy to use configurator allows
you to customize each component of your
build to your desire so even someone
like Chris can build a PC yes and each
PC is meticulously cable managed to
ensure neatness and tested to ensure
stability and performance all their PCS
are powered by Windows 11 playtime
anytime so get a discount on your next
order at PC specialist by visiting the
link down below and using coupon code
trash at the checkout thank you to PC
specialist for sponsoring this episode
back to the video all right I found a
chart radiation dose chart so uh
sleeping next to someone this is from
XKCD sleeping next to somebody is 0.05
micro sieverts okay which is nothing uh
background
background radiation dose received by an
average person over one normal day is 10
Micro sieverts okay a flight from New
York to La's 40 micro sieverts
just existing you get background
radiation a dental x-ray is five micro
sieverts
well the less than the average day that
you get yes
oh and the plane is 40 40. so it's like
dead and five of those I suppose yeah
huh so then the chest x-ray is 20 micro
sieverts so that's half a plane yeah
yeah
okay so if you sit on a plane from L.A
to New York that is you're getting two
extra you're getting two chest x-rays
okay what's what's up on that list uh by
the end of trash tease tour we're gonna
be like glowing
Conor's gonna I'm gonna have like a
third arm can't just gonna transform
into the Hulk
the epa's yearly release Target for a
nuclear power plant 30 micro secrets
well just being working so I think it's
I think so yes I think it sounds like
it's very strict basically you can't
have any variation leaking
from the PowerPoint a day
um
yearly oh and maybe release I'm not
really sure exactly 30 yearly
uh no every every year 30 micro Savers
Jesus
um it just gets worse and worse too when
you get because it all depends I think
on like where the x-rays are going yeah
yeah it can be really bad and whatnot
but long story short uh it's it's not
that bad I think eating one banana is
1.1 micro Siever so yeah I remember if
you ate 50 bananas that's one dental
x-ray I mean [ __ ] that's fine that's
what my daily diet yeah
I should just x-ray myself as that yeah
so x-raying your hand wasn't that
dangerous but a few people were freaking
out I remember the comments yeah like
what the [ __ ] yeah and I talked to some
someone I went to high school with is a
like basically like a radiation kind of
engineer for medical equipment and she
basically said like if it's not a big
deal
um good yeah but disclaimer it is not
good please don't do it at home please
don't go and go buying x-rays it's like
drinking alcohol like would you ever
tell somebody that drinking alcohol was
healthy no no
but but alcohol is like you know I think
it's because it's like you can't see it
yeah it's scary yeah I don't know what's
happening like media too has built it up
it's not like this crazy cancer cause it
comes from space yeah
I mean that led that led into the video
about you getting like hate comments as
well which I thought was amazing yeah
and a lot of people got mad at that one
of course they're gonna get [ __ ] even
like friends I know who don't want your
channel yeah they they who are YouTubers
have watched that video yeah because
it's I think it's something that a lot
of people in the industry or field can
relate to a lot yeah have you seen this
video no I've seen it yeah okay well
it's explain explain the video so I'm
very much a noob when it comes to your
channel that's fine it's fine uh I had
done a video in the past where I like
like kind of looked at hate comments or
comments where it was like I think
buying when I bought it bought a
battlebot okay and some people I knew it
was gonna drive some people from nuts
and so I took some of those comments and
kind of made a humorous video around it
and I'm like oh I did the X-ray video
and got the same thing I was like I'll
do the same thing yeah uh but I uh
someone was pretending to be an expert
yeah and so I the average basically
reached out to them and I kind of made
them talk in a way that revealed they
were not really that much of an expert
okay because I've had a lot of
interactions online related to like
engineering and safety which are kind of
frustrating because like some of us say
we do stuff is like not super safe
but not crazy dangerous like I'm
probably a lot safer than most people
think uh like I remember long ago I made
a video where I was testing safety
glasses with my laser cutter and there
was a comment talking about not having
to wear safety glasses around laser
cutter he works with but like what the
guy was completely missing was that the
laser cutter I had uses like a mid-range
infrared light yeah and the laser cutter
he was using is like a near IR so like
near IR will go right through your
cornea whereas the mid-range will like
basically stop at your cornea I mean
it'll still burn the crap out of your
eye but yeah and so you end up with like
people are very willing to communicate
educate completely like wrong
information which is terrifying in a
confident tone yes exactly it's like you
know you're talking about something that
could like blind people yeah and it's
like no you don't need to do that I
don't want to do I don't do this and
it's like oh my God and I remember like
you know replying to him I don't really
I don't reply to commenting this is
years ago and I said like are you
talking about like fiber lasers like
this is really different blah blah and
it's like oh yeah I didn't I guess I
guess that that's not and it's like if
somebody read this they're gonna I was
like oh okay I guess I don't need to
yeah exactly so I get really frustrated
sometimes seeing like the kind of like
the technical talking people just say
you think I mean that's what I do in the
podcast I just say [ __ ] that I'm I'm
confident about that is completely wrong
right I mean we all do that all three of
us do of course yeah we've done that
plenty of times I'm like I'm incredibly
paranoid about doing that I don't know
why other than like for safety stuff
explicitly like I do not understand a
lot more with when you're making stuff
and safety stuff that you would take
that a lot more seriously yeah if you
say the wrong thing about an anime
series it's not a life yeah so our
audience knows not to listen to
[ __ ] clowns to begin with anyway but
I guess I guess with you all expertise
and how how your content is like what
your content is about I can see why
people would I guess pay more attention
to that right yeah there's a bit more
severity to you know saying the wrong
thing I feel so I try to put disclaimers
where it's like I'm not an expert or I
think this is how it works yeah right in
that way it's kind of like here I'm
gonna fuzz it a little bit this is what
I'm pretty sure how it works but also
you know I don't quite me I've been on
the internet for a couple hours
researching it and I think you know like
for the CT scanner I think I've watched
maybe like four hours of college
lectures about CT scanning and like
computer typography it's like does that
make me an expert no but I also wrote a
python script that does you know CT
maths where do I fall I don't know well
I've always actually wondered actually
because talking talking to you and
talking to a lot of people on safety
third and a lot of people involved in
this side of YouTube it seems like you
guys are more than anyone else in
YouTube willing to risk safety to make
good content yeah what is your line
because we had Nigel on last week and
and that was just kind of like he has no
like that that was just like
interviewing a Serial arsonist yeah I
also wanted to ask you like I'm not the
most dangerous YouTuber I'm like who is
the most dangerous the most dangerous I
could probably so there's a rock okay so
here's the thing when we do stuff
we are always aware of the risk yeah and
like we're not going to put ourselves in
a situation where we're like knowingly
doing something really bad yeah and a
lot of times people will see something
that is dangerous yeah and then that's
like immediate Panic where it's like oh
there's high voltage or oh there's this
that's dangerous that's dangerous and
it's like you know what like if how do
you think they made helicopters yeah
you think they just built a helicopter
and it worked the first time
I was like I thought you were alluding
to some like horrible helicopter-based
accident I [ __ ] you're not there's just
a horrible amazing video of like the guy
who's like piloting one of the first
helicopters it's like vibrating and it
like bounces and the rotor kicks them
and like launches him and he's like
totally fine that's what they said at
least
he's paralyzed apparently he kept flying
it maybe yeah I I could be wrong but I
remember it I'm not an Xbox I don't know
the video I'm pretty sure I've been
around some videos to see on the inside
like some of the compilations of like
near-death compilations on YouTube and
then like disclaimer all of these people
are fired and I'm like can I get a
source for that I see some of these
Cliffs and they definitely don't [ __ ]
look have you heard of the Ford Pinto no
no like one of the big issues with you
know car manufacturing back in the day I
think it's like the 70s or 60s right
when they get rear-ended the doors would
jam so it would compress the frame oh
yeah they crumple now right yeah and so
you couldn't open the doors and then
they would also like catch on fire right
and so the decision was to pay out the
claims as opposed to fix the design flaw
that to me is a huge No-No when it comes
to Danger like I'm not going to put
other people's lives yeah right unless
they understand what we're doing okay
that makes sense so I'm willing to put
myself in age I'm willing to put you
know like Kevin the backyard scientist
them in danger but also at the same time
they are well aware of what the danger
is yeah yeah I mean they're educated on
the stuff yeah yeah so what is your line
I guess uh I would be mortified if I
hurt somebody out like who was not in
that kind of right yes there are a few
chopped Allen's Lego for something you'd
be like oh well you know at least we got
the shot we probably wouldn't get far
enough into something unless it was like
a horrific accident yeah so like when we
we did this car video recently
yeah that's great it took me like six
months to edit that one too
um and we like you know basically cut
the frame of the car apart take the roof
off and we drove it around town and it's
like we're going 30 miles an hour hour
yeah yeah for a couple miles
it's like not a big deal yeah like
what's the worst that happened this car
just go like yeah and then comes to like
us like a grinding Hall yeah right so
that I'm not too worried about and like
nothing happened anyways because like if
you cut the roof off a car and it falls
apart because of that I mean the car was
clearly not very strong yeah that's the
coast that's the gospel
like imagine imagine somebody like hits
the top of your car and all of a sudden
structural in Texas
off a plane if it doesn't fly well
that's the kind of the place
so who is the most the most dangerous
the most dangerous that I can think of
off the top of my head right now is this
Russian Channel called creoson
that's like that's like a cop-out answer
it's Russian they're insane and it's
amazing or maybe they're ukraining I
don't really know it's like an example
so they go to like Chernobyl they've
gone to Chernobyl Bunch yeah
um okay and just sort of done things
there that like like I I think I'm
pretty sure they snuck in I think they
snuck into like a Russian like the
Russian uh space shuttle facility which
is like Supergirl started and it's just
like this like rotting corpse of a space
shuttle yeah but like the Russian one
right and it's just on YouTube yeah it's
just on YouTube yeah and like there's
like security and stuff that they're
sneaking past and like they panic when
they like crawl up in and everything so
they're like climbing on you know
ancient scaffolding that's like not been
taken care of at all and it's like at
any point in time stuff could fall apart
don't really make me anxious and I'm
watching no I don't really fear for your
safety at any point in the video I
posted it's true true some other people
I'm like oh my god what the [ __ ] this
could go very wrong yeah yeah I
definitely play stuff up too yeah I mean
I mean you do for the contest it's good
content like we bought the X-ray machine
like the first time we made it work was
actually me and Kevin the backyard
scientists so we were in my garage we
put it together hooked it all up and
then what's in the video is essentially
me kind of like going through the
process again yeah because it's really
difficult to try to film a process like
that in an entertaining way yeah yeah so
it's like I already knew what I was
doing and what looks dangerous like it's
not not dangerous but it's also being
kind of done in a safe enough way right
yeah but I'm not like getting my hands
in there not getting too close to it
it's like every time I turn that thing
on I know it's on and when I'm done I
ground it like it's being very very step
by step very procedural with like I'm
not gonna put myself damn illusion
broken I can even watch that video the
same way again
but it really just is you know it's just
entertainment yeah of course yeah what's
the most dangerous thing that has
happened guys
that dog seemed very dangerous which was
on I did a thing though that one you're
helping yeah so that one is do you want
to explain the video you made it look
I'm sort of they they just strapped a
machine gun to it like a Boston Dynamic
discount yeah a discount I was kind of
disappointed it wasn't the legit the
company is so mad at him oh really
I'm not surprised it's really funny
they're sending him DM's because he
tried to buy one a while ago right all
right so they're sending him DMS of like
oh we like your video could you tell us
the serial number of your robot again
they're they're like trying to shut the
robots
it's gonna become like it's got a taste
of guns yeah it can't be quenched yeah
it's Cynthia now
[Music]
because nobody wants you to do this
because it's bad but the thing is like
that video I think like I'm really glad
like I I like you know I don't know I
feel like Engineers are like I like I
like the idea of all that stuff but
there's something that you need to be
able to describe to people like black
mirrorship like this is a real
possibility and you need to be like you
want this to surprise you yeah yeah or
do you want somebody to be like taking
shortcuts to try to show you this
technology is basically possible yeah
yeah I I didn't watch that video
thinking oh wow this area responsible
putting a gun on another bike the
military is going to put a gun on a dog
yeah I mean they're putting it on the
dog regardless we want it we should just
you know we should be aware this is
gonna happen and so it's like is that
scary the military is gonna put a gun on
those dogs
who was in the set that's like uh world
war three we do not know what kind of
weapons
there's like a shot of like the hills
and just like okay
because the red coats are coming
he's putting a gun on a dog any
different from putting bombs in a UAV
like really like that's the same thing
yes it's just scarier because it's a dog
it's terrifying it's like that's the
thing I like I had two safeties on it so
I had two remote controls one of them
was controlling a Servo to pull the
trigger the other one literally
interrupted the power to the servo so I
could disconnect the servo power it's
not even like a signal or anything it's
actually just straight up cutting power
to the servo motor yeah so if that was
disabled nothing would happen yeah right
and I had two of them and it so I had to
turn one on and then turn the other one
and then you get to shoot and it's still
scary because like you at some point you
have to load the thing and then walk
away from it and in that time like
that's like I don't know like that's
where things go wrong if something's
gonna go wrong that's where it's gonna
go wrong yeah they seem crazy because I
remember when I met you in L.A for the
first time you're telling me about this
idea and I was like this is insane yeah
it also sounds really interesting
yeah that's where I met you and you
offered to lend the microphone oh yeah
yeah so I mean you basically save trash
taste yeah thank you very much thank you
you're welcome we wouldn't have an LA
Arc if it wasn't for Williams yeah we
didn't want the cameras because they
weren't high enough quality no because
we already rented cameras we need 4K
what I sound like Oliver Twist
well we let you lend our setup and
you're like oh we want to film a 1080
I'm like why the [ __ ] do you want to
film a 1080 plus footage easier to edit
it looks awful nowadays it's you guys
are the trash flavor podcast you're
afraid you're the guys
there's only two you can't take it
because a robot dog or we're suing why'd
you say that as if garbage flavor was
the first one to come out
did people send it to you how did you
see it did you not we got a few funny
guys we've got some memes out there yeah
we're like we don't even know who you
are
who's stealing our [ __ ]
yeah do you remember like back in the
day with uh FPS Russia that's probably
that's probably like the most dangerous
like content I've seen on the most
famous clip of the truck exploding and
like the shrapnel like going right past
him the giant door oh yeah kills him yes
I mean that's that's like the worst one
but that was several times like it's
caught on camera where you can see
exploding shrapnel one of them was I
think was like a fridge door or
something oh I think I've seen that one
yeah there's a fridge door and there's
one truck nothing nothing
yeah and you can literally see his life
almost ending if he just stood a few
inches to his left to his right and I'm
just like how this is the this was the
real wild west of YouTube man holy have
you ever watched gun YouTube videos yeah
whatever FPS Russia back in the day yeah
that was like
that was it nowadays it feels less tame
I've seen some videos of stuff and
there's this one video of the dude
getting this like I blown out from a 50
Barrett caliber or something that's
crazy
like the gun
explanation or something like that yeah
like flies back and like he's like his
dad like saved his life or something
YouTube watch see the explosion I think
you see I don't think it's super graphic
right but you know it's bad he
essentially goes he does like a whole
breakdown of like what it's a really
interesting video it's a good watch but
like it's still even like the stuff that
they do nowadays doesn't seem as crazy
as like what FPS Russia was doing no
YouTube kids yeah
that man was a YouTuber through and
through because if have you seen the
interviews where people ask him about
like about did they feel dangerous and
he was like so if you didn't know FPS
Russia is an old school YouTuber
um who it was this Russian guy who
basically just tested guns and just shot
them at EX things that exploded until
afterwards it came out that he wasn't
Russian at all
saying how he got that license that lets
him to buy any of the yeah crazy guns
yeah yeah wild you can do it yeah
I looked into it really yeah because I
was curious because I'm like wait a
second because machine guns are Outlaw
they're outlawed by like I think Reagan
in 1984. yeah
um and that was not a total ban on them
it just created very strict rules around
them you can still do it and there's a
couple ways of doing it and it's a whole
Nightmare and it's why nobody not many
people do it it doesn't I thought I was
under the impression that YouTube If it
like had gone in the title or had guns
they definitely would it would like
demonetize and demonetize it yeah I
don't I just don't do anything yeah I
mean like someone like FPS Russia aside
from what happened to him couldn't exist
in this no there's no way yeah because
like I was saying like when you when you
go back to his interviews and people ask
him were you scared and he was like well
yeah me I can't remember his real name I
think it's like Nick or something
something like that like me I was
[ __ ] myself but FPS Russia he
wouldn't be scared
so
I wouldn't need safety glass so if
Russia wouldn't eat safety uh safety
glass or a safety barrier then I would I
love that that's just like man this this
man was YouTube's first ever method
actor yeah yeah that's insane so I love
that like that's that's insane but yeah
it's insane that he basically got away
with his life so many times multiple
times yeah doing this insane [ __ ] on
YouTube you guys watching Mythbusters at
all yeah oh I love him they did really
[Music]
shot into a city
what yeah
into a house someone's house yeah what
not close yeah goes far
I do know that like the first couple of
seasons of Mythbusters was very much
like an experimental phase I think where
they were just like how much could we
get away with but then I think as the
show got bigger they were just like yeah
all right we probably have to be careful
because I think like in early Seasons
there was like an accident that happened
where like an explosion went off and
like Adam's eyebrow just got completely
singed off he like loses his entire
eyebrow what and it's like it wasn't
planned it looks like it wasn't planned
he's just like yeah I've just lost an
eyebrow
they did like they blew up a cement
truck too I think that oh that one was
crazy I just I feel like it's like they
were kind of approaching stuff that you
really only see like the military do but
the military has like squaws of land
that they'll just like go in the middle
of some Canyon that's like yeah why do
they blow up a cement truck
because they could I guess yeah I mean
tell me right now if you guys had the
opportunity to blow up a cement truck
you wouldn't do it
I do vividly remember that episode and
the the sound of the explosion doesn't
sound real it's it's like the type of
explosion you would only hear in like
video games because it's just so insane
it's like it's like because you just see
it it is like a tiny cement truck way
off in the distance and then a second
later it's just gone it's just smoke and
then they they walk up to and they're
like they said there was nothing there
was nothing left it's just like it just
turned to dust and I'm like and again I
don't remember why they did it yeah
I would do it if I had the opportunity
yeah I mean that's
yeah I haven't seen that clip but I have
to watch that clip yeah that sounds
insane it's it's so entertaining yeah
but also like even there are some other
TV shows that seem like they could do
some possible dangerous dangerous stuff
I'm thinking about like old school Top
Gear as well like I wonder how much
safety precautions they did in some of
their stunts like do you remember I
can't remember if it was the Vietnam
special what it was like one of the like
Asia specials where they had to drive
across this really really narrow road I
mean you can't fake that yeah you can't
really fake that right but I think it's
a lot like I'm not gonna say it's less
safe than it looks but I think that it's
a lot more real than people think it is
yeah yeah yeah I think sometimes people
because you you've it's it's Ed so
you're like oh they lived so it's
totally fine right so it's really easy
to do but that's I say like you know you
look at all the US rocket programs and
everything like you know what I'm saying
lots of people die doing that and it's
like would you rather have your cell
phone
and a couple people in the day the good
old days died yeah developing all the
technology leading up to that or we
don't ever try anything crazy like
helicopters so you think you think we
need crazy people
right now you know you you're literally
in the Mad the Mad scientists
mindset yeah I mean like if I don't
strap a gun to a dog someone else
it's like that it's like I mean with the
flying cars it's like Society if
everyone was crazy
you're being flying cars right now yeah
I definitely like I I can totally
understand
imagine like raising a kid right oh
never go outside never touch the door
handle it might be dirty never do this
yeah ah you know then you're gonna have
a weird sheltered kid that doesn't learn
any real life experience yeah and so
it's like yeah
there's do your parents ever give you
any concerns about some of the safety in
your videos or not no I think they're
used to it I mean I've almost I almost
burned my parents house down once
specifically that was bad what is it
with science YouTube isn't awesome
I was just like you know doing like the
aerosol flamethrower but I used uh
carburetor cleaner
oh my God which is like its own solvent
but it's like an aerosol with a solvent
and so it's like oh my God and so what
you did in like the living room it just
went straight up in the garage and it
like something in the ceiling caught on
fire is this just a rye of Passage to
every science or engineering yeah you
must have like almost blown up or set
your house on fire yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
I didn't know how to go to that
transition I kind of I kind of realized
that I said it
if there's one video on your channel I
have seen it's that one I cannot believe
somebody took it from me that was my job
oh you wanted to be the one who did it
yeah were the insurance fraud and
everything did you get it exactly I mean
if you think about it though like that's
what everybody else thought they're like
oh you burned your house down I'm like
actually think that I'm not anymore but
there was dude there was I've never
experienced anything Yeah you mentioned
in the hate video about how obviously
people's donating to the GoFundMe and
that was really stressful because people
felt like you owed people yeah yeah like
what like what was going through your
head with all of that stuff like it just
seemed like I mean I I don't even know
how I would begin to process if that
happened to me I think that like I do
pretty well in like high stress
situations where it kind of just goes
like full logic brain
um and in that situation it's like okay
just move forward move forward move
forward so it's like what is the most
reasonable thing to do right now yeah
and at the time it was just get
everything organized continue to post
videos
um try to you know find a new place to
live but like I think we ended up living
in the motorhome for like eight months
yeah in an RV in my parents driveway if
my house button down posting videos
would be the last yeah yeah honestly it
was it was like the only thing I had
though yeah I had lost everything like
all my tools like I did I saved my
computer but I never set it up because I
didn't have anywhere to put it up so
like because I mean obviously I saw the
video but like I don't know what was
happening like did you like did you have
insurance for your place or it's like
did you get did you get we had got
renters insurance three months before
wow
and that actually like saved our asses
because the day of we immediately went
to uh cash like a three thousand dollar
check for the from the renters yeah
right because otherwise it was like we
didn't have any money yeah
did you know because obviously having I
imagine that like losing a lot of your
possessions and stuff like that that's
got to change how you like view
everything yeah like like how does it
shift how you feel about
um I think it was like a forced
exploration where it was like okay I
can't do what I've been doing yeah so I
have to figure out a way to keep doing
stuff and try to be entertaining and
nice sorry
my ADHD just went go for it and it was
also weird too because I had spent a
bunch of time kind of just I don't know
how to describe it but like you know you
said you're like watching anime just as
a hobby like when I built the laser
cutter that kind of was the big start of
my channel like I had built that as a
hobby like I was saying like oh maybe I
could make some money with it maybe I
can make parts for people but like I
wanted that for me because the guy that
used to have one near me moved and so
once the house burned down I was so
focused on just making videos that like
I felt like I didn't have any time to
kind of like re-establish anything like
making a new laser cutter or building a
workshop it was just kind of like video
video video video video right and so it
was a very kind of like a realization
that I need to definitely like figure
out how to separate myself from making
videos so that I can do other stuff to
kind of almost build up what you would
actually use in your day-to-day life to
make the videos if that makes any sense
at all yeah yeah yeah I mean like I I
can sympathize with what you go through
but I don't even know what I how I would
act
my brain my brain would just shut down
yeah yeah
I don't know I have no idea how I mean
we had you know like the GoFundMe was a
huge safety net like we actually ended
up like I didn't pull the money out of
there for a long time we were just sort
of still living yeah because I didn't
know what to do I genuinely did not know
what to do I did not know if I was gonna
get like screwed on taxes it's gonna be
like conflicting like should I yeah use
it and I never had anything like I think
you know the most money I'd ever had in
my account was working entirely through
college I think I saved it like fifteen
thousand dollars yeah and then over the
couple years after college basically got
down to like nothing and Chelsea had the
only jobs like I wasn't working she was
paying rent I had like nothing yeah and
so all of a sudden it's like I don't I
don't know I don't know what to do like
I don't I literally don't have to do
like normally I buy groceries and pay
gas yeah with my money that I make I've
never had an opportunity to figure
something else out yeah and you
mentioned in the video you're like you
felt bad that you'd like uh have a Tesla
or something
um yeah I mean there was a joke in one
of the early videos where like we did
like a special effects of like a
cardboard cutout of a Tesla yeah yeah I
feel like a lot of YouTubers feel like
that they're like I don't want to I
don't want people to like think I have
money yeah right and then must be like
Amplified even more so when people give
you that money people would say really
bad things for a while and it just sort
of helped to like feed into the people
said stuff immediately like we a guy
that we're still friends with uh that
used to work at Disney invited us to
come work it is there to come to Disney
it was like totally like out of the blue
like yeah I work at Disney I can get you
in for free so we went and visited and
he got it he used his family passes to
get us in and posted a picture on
Instagram and it's like of course some
of the comments everybody people like
why you would just yeah oh I see you're
spending the money well already it's
like oh my God
money existed before yeah that's all the
money you guys gave me I can spend my
money like you didn't keep all your
money under your mattress yeah it was
you know you have a bank account for a
reason and it's like I would love to do
more stuff and like we've been trying to
do more stuff with money because I think
it's fun to like expand and I think a
lot of people don't understand that
running a YouTube channel like there's
two parts of it you've got kind of the
art side of it and you've got the
business side of it absolutely like
there's people that work for me yeah
yeah like I've had people working for me
for the past like you know four years
like I have to pay them yeah yeah
absolutely a lot of people will forget
that now it's like if you see some big
YouTubers they probably have a team
behind them yes and like I've gone out
of my way like we we've tried as hard as
we can so like any way that works for us
has like health insurance yeah like
there's places that's that's a big thing
in the US yeah especially when they work
for you exactly they need to like double
up on health insurance so we figured out
how to like uh you know we have a small
company that does brand deals for a lot
of science channels and everybody that
works there is health insurance and like
I don't pay for that directly it just
sort of runs itself right um but that
has sort of been like a blessing for
everybody yeah because it kind of helps
to like unify us a little bit so people
can't screw us over
um and we're doing you know a bunch of
merchandising stuff now and I have my
friend Ian who's working on the Channel
full time and it's like these are all
people that are working full-time you
have to pay them it's like you gotta
absolutely and you're in California and
it's in California
it can be frustrating sometimes when
people say stuff like oh like you know
three thousand dollars and month and
it's like oh my God if you could hire
somebody for 3 000 like you know how
much money it cost to hire somebody yeah
if you guys in California makes two
thousand dollars a month aren't you just
maybe getting by I don't know the
immediate that's not great in California
I don't no no
is that possible you could you could do
it yeah but you'd be like an apartment
with roommates and stuff right right
it's like it's it's in a lot of places
that would be a lull yeah but in LA and
California that is nothing no especially
if your company's not paying you health
insurance or anything do you need to pay
for that on your own or if you're like a
contractor freelance like I work for
myself and it's like oh yeah then you
gotta pay self-employment tax and you
gotta get yourself health insurance
you're from California yeah right yeah
obviously from L.A so you've just been
in California a whole lot there's no
party there's like yeah just get a giant
piece of land I think about it all the
time yeah the problem is like my family
lives there like what am I supposed to
do that's true move your family over as
well I mean I live here my family
certainly is not from here yeah
how do you see them now I mean do you
want to see them I do I do I have you
seen that um I'm I'm sure you watch a
curse Gazette yes did you watch a video
where they talk about the how often like
how much you'll have seen your family
and in like your entire life oh yeah
I immediately texted my mom
in this video they basically explained
that like by age 18 you will have spent
like 90 of your of the time with your
family that you will ever yeah that
makes a lot of sense and that's like
that was such a sobering and depressing
thought but it's true yeah yeah it made
me want to really try more but also I
being on the other side of the world uh
makes it a lot harder what's that flight
yeah it kind of just cries a single tier
while living in Japan thousand like
halfway across the world from his mom I
was just like I did I was like Mom I
love you it's great you're an amazing
parent you're so good but well I Skype
them all the time yeah yeah so I feel
like that's better than some I like I
call my parents at least like two three
times a week that's good that's right
yeah that's quite a large other people
that's because they wanna I don't know
why they just want to call me up and
talk to me about random [ __ ] I don't
know do they like the YouTube stuff oh
yeah they they've really gotten into it
recently the first three four years they
were like we don't get it
um and then ever since trash taste
um and oh you make money now we get it
yeah well the ever since they kind of
saw like 10 bucks they were excited yeah
they thought that was really the same
with my yeah they were like wait so you
just made 10 bucks from posting a video
from doing that cringe thing you do in
your room yeah
they were always really supportive but
they didn't really like get it yeah and
then ever since I kind of made my
content more focused around just doing
kind of more showing off kind of bizarre
side of the Japan where which anyone can
watch you can any any age group you can
watch this and understand what's
happening uh they watch it a lot more
and they they actively tell me about my
videos now yeah which is kind of good
and bad yeah yeah yeah
my parents watch Trash taste every week
I don't know how they do it God's
parents are going to know who you are
yeah yeah exactly exactly
like it was so weird [ __ ] going back
home this uh these last few months and
then like Friday would come around yeah
I'd come downstairs I'm like why do I
hear my voice
and they would be watching trash teeth
Dad I'm right here if you want to talk
to me talk to me in real life I would
not be able to handle it did they not
watch your videos my mom does your dad
my dad my dad's my dad
my mom is like a fan yeah yeah yeah my
mom is what's that Meme of like if
William has a million fans I'm one of
them yeah 100
000 fans that's my mom I'm there in the
front row
that makes sense that's so cute that's
very funny I mean like at this point
because we live halfway across the world
my parents use YouTube as a way to keep
up with what I'm doing yeah they're like
did trash taste upload this weekend okay
my son's alive yeah yeah it's so weird
like whenever whenever I call my parents
and then they bring up something I'm
just like
oh my God I'm sharing too much yeah oh
my God it happens all the time like even
like like people who you sort of
casually know or don't know they'll
leave a comment about something and
you're like where did I say they're like
oh my God this podcast like oh my God
what am I talking about
like oh people listen to that yeah I
don't know do your parents watch safety
third at all what do you think I don't
think so your mom has watched it
yeah because like I think there was
there was like me before trash Chase and
then everything I've said after trash
days my pet I sometimes I'd say a story
or something in my childhood my parents
be like you [ __ ] why do why
didn't you tell us this you're talking
[ __ ] about us on your podcast my dad's
done that to me so many times where he's
just like yeah that thing you said like
four episodes ago you're so full of [ __ ]
and I was like yeah
I said something in a video where I was
like I made a joke about my childhood
that was like sarcastic you know like I
don't remember what it was my mom was
like that's not true like almost like
like I was like Mom yeah they're like no
no it's just a joke I don't I don't
think most people think it's yeah I
think oh sorry oh man yeah I I think
especially YouTube videos are much more
fun because you can control it but trash
taste and podcasts in general you spew
so much things that you don't even
remember saying I don't know what I said
yeah I've said so much stuff yeah yeah
it's just they just come out the words
just come out oh you have to you can't
do this for like an episode no I don't
remember half the [ __ ] I said in this
episode yeah to be honest
you were talking about weird stuff
I probably yeah I'm not even surprised
every time I open my mouth
so yeah I mean you're in Japan
yeah
I wanted to get you on in LA but then uh
like because we had a bunch of other
things scheduled and it just it didn't
work yeah
absolutely packed we're here because of
you guys yeah oh well I I didn't do
anything
thank you thank you directed you towards
the years yeah he was mailing but it was
using the credit that's fine from when
did we meet now we met at that uh party
uh yeah in June so and we're what August
now yeah yeah yes so from the middle of
June to the middle of August like yeah
literally it was like oh crazy Japan
okay and then two months later we're in
Japan oh yeah I mean I I feel like
sometimes you meet YouTubers you're like
oh you're like a normal dude who just
also makes YouTube videos and you get
along really well and I was like oh yeah
you should definitely come again yeah
a lot of times you sound like to meet
people you're like oh oh my God you are
a lot yeah yeah there's a lot of those
yeah I was surprised that you decided to
come to Japan this quickly because
mostly you meet someone who like oh do
you want to come here to this place I'm
like yeah one day and then like two
years passes and then you get the
message but you guys was just like I
love to just be impulsive with stuff
like this right well it's just it's like
everything lines up it makes sense let's
do it like don't don't and like there's
enough help now he's like I I'm a very
one-track mind and I don't know if
that's if everybody else is like that or
if it's just me but it's like if I have
to start trying to do too many things at
the same time everything falls apart I
get nothing so yeah being able to have
people that help organize stuff just
like okay what do you think about Japan
they're like okay and then they just
start working on it it's like
oh my God it's really really so you came
for the first time in 2019 yeah and you
just loved it yeah this place is amazing
I honestly I think if anybody has any
intention of ever coming to Japan you
have to do it it has to be in your
bucket list you have to come to Japan
make it figure out how to make it work
what's so good about it
you tell me yeah
Tokyo is everything every major city
wishes it was
it is like America but Disneyland mixing
the same thing where it's like a city
that I'm familiar enough with yeah
because it's like a lot of everything is
like English or like you know uses our
alphabets yeah you can write it and
decipher it yeah um but it's like clean
and convenient and predictable like it's
it's bizarre because it's like Los
Angeles is a nightmare
this is great traffic isn't too bad yeah
right public transport system as well we
have yet to run into any issues with
public transport like we're not maybe
we're just avoiding rush hour and
whatnot but like you show up and oh oh
but even the changes even during rush
hour it somehow works yeah you just have
to deal with the crowd but like it's
just it's just craps it's just cramps
but everything's still on time somehow
yeah I just like when we normally back
home like I don't drink at all when we
go out because I'm driving yeah you're
just like yeah yeah I drink every day I
have a beer two beers well that was one
thing that was one thing as someone who
grew up in England I could never
understand about American culture which
is this culture of having a designated
driver because I'm like damn imagine if
you have to go out and one of you just
has to like commit to not having fun you
know like I couldn't I wouldn't I just
wouldn't go out you know like like even
if there's just that one time yeah
because in Australia it's not who's the
designated driver it's who's the least
drunk here
yeah
I know everyone everyone's doing it
we do not condone that at all
oh no I've never done that okay okay I
must have ever done that Australia is a
very interesting place you should come
to Australia it's kind of like white
trash America but also at the same time
it's like way more together hold on
pause
[Music]
what did you say
Australia is like white trash America
yeah
I think it's right
but it's nice
I mean I don't I don't mean that
wholeheartedly
but I still stand by it like there's
something a little bit crazier wait have
you been to Australia yeah once
whereabouts were you uh Melbourne oh
okay okay like there's something about
us
maybe maybe I should also I'm gonna I'm
gonna add a loophole it could have also
been the people that I was hanging out
yeah it might have been
well I guess like yeah there was a lot
of crazy [ __ ] that happens in Australia
oh absolutely I mean yeah like Australia
is like the Florida of the world oh
absolutely yeah absolutely that's what I
mean yeah yeah no okay okay I get it in
that sense yes definitely it is what's
the difference between Florida and white
trash
[Music]
drag me faster
there's something in the water in
Florida there's something in the war in
Australia as well yeah this place I like
Japan a lot yeah I like Australia too it
was either we were going to go back to
Australia come to Japan it's it's nice
going to Australia or the UK or America
after being here for too long because
you after a while you kind of get bogged
down by all the rules and all the things
you've been following okay I just want
to go somewhere where when there's a
problem that people figure it out not
people are so freaking out and going um
um what do we do what do we do this guy
said he wants to tippers
yeah I mean it's it's it's weird because
I think visiting Japan is I think I
honestly do think Japan is one of the
best countries to visit in the world uh
if you want to live here there's other
things you have to keep in mind it's
still an amazing country to live in but
it's a very different experience
is perfect and definitely after you know
being stuck in there for covid I did
miss a lot of let's say like the chiller
aspects of other countries
yeah yeah when it comes to just attitude
right yeah I think attitude is a big
thing where sometimes you just want to
go to a place or you know work somewhere
where you don't have to worry about
getting approval or just should I be
worried about doing this very specific
thing you know a very specific thing
with little to no consequences but they
make it seem like there's a whole heap
of consequences I like I like I totally
find following the rules if they make
sense
a lot of America has stuff that doesn't
make sense too yeah have you ever
learned about like the drug
classifications like the drug scaling no
I think the UK actually follows
similarly to uh marijuana is classified
worse than methamphetamine wait what
what so we're in the UK that we have
like a b yeah so marijuana I'm gonna
double check that out yeah are you an
expert well I mean we've talked about it
before I mean as you know drug experts
here you know yeah of course you know
recent drug experts yeah yeah but yeah I
believe in the UK marijuana is a Class C
drug yeah cocaine and ecstasy and all
those are like cast class A drugs I was
like I've never heard of what a Class B
drug is so schedule one speed schedule
one is marijuana heroin LSD ecstasy blah
blah and then of course nowhere in these
are like nicotine yeah yeah or anything
like that right and so it's like to me
that's one of those rules where it's
like from like a scientific stand like
standpoint like there's definitely like
no science has been done yeah yeah if
you want to have rules government like
right exactly right and so it's like be
concise and be like realistic with the
rules don't just make [ __ ] up yeah yeah
I mean that could apply to a lot of
things though right yeah like yes some
things I I feel like just have to do
with like PR or the let's say the public
perception of them yeah I mean I would
argue Japan does that but in the
opposite end when it comes to things
like marijuana do they just think like
oh all drugs are just as bad as each
other so marijuana is just as bad as
heroin and meth and all of us
surprisingly lacks in some places though
but I think it's because they haven't
ever had like big disasters or anything
so there's some some rules you're like
that's weirdly okay like weirdly okay
with it I
um there's a few I I had some things in
mind I forgot but like the fact that you
can drink alcohol in a lot of places
that you normally think that other
countries will be like maybe don't like
you openly drink alcohol no problem
right the culture around alcohol here is
really you drink alcohol I'll call in
public yeah absolutely you do not go on
the train you can drink alcohol on a
busy but I'll tell you what you can't do
in public okay smoke cigarettes
you can smoke cigarettes inside in a
restaurant in certain restaurants or in
designated smoking areas
you can't smoke outside on the streets
where are you supposed to that seems
like the only place you would go
welcome to Japan when you get a domestic
flight you don't need to show an idea at
any point that's cool you just walk on
the plane yeah I mean that I get because
it's America that's not how it is
they got 911 though so yeah yeah
they spend every single year I look this
up also I'm like 90 certain after 9 11
I'm just saying everything right they
spend more money every single year than
it costs to build the towers
they're not very good wow wow I had this
horrible thought experiment I don't know
if Alan used this at all but the idea
was would you rather when something bad
does happen you pay out the families all
that money
and not spend it on the TSA
Oh that's oh
this is this is the trolley argument
just just framed differently I swear to
God
I had like a really [ __ ] scary
encounter when I was in uh it wasn't
scary we were in uh LAX yeah and uh you
know because I have my I have my bag
right which has every single wire and
Battery oh yeah so I always gets flagged
every single they hate my bags they stop
it every time they make me open it up
they make me [ __ ] and it's a mess so
it looks it doesn't look good it's not
neat it's a lot of batteries batteries
wires wires camera yeah you know it's
always a thing and I'm I'm used to it
happening every single time yeah so I
see my bag go in you know because it
goes down then it can get like shuttle
to the side yeah yes yes oh yeah when
you see it when you see it pop out of
the size
I said I'm waiting
I'm waiting and then as I'm like seeing
my bag go down this other thing I'm like
[ __ ] sake I gotta tap on the shoulder
and I turn around and it's TSA this is
guy big dude there's a like a smaller
guy and there's a bigger guy behind him
and he's like are you Connor and I'm
like yes yeah what's wrong he's like
there's a really long pause and he's
like I love trash taste by this
because this was on the flight to Miami
right uh uh yeah no Australia oh it's
Australia we just got we'd flown from
Miami to L.A to get a flight yeah that's
right and I and I had already like gone
off because I got all my [ __ ] and so
from the distance I just saw Connor
getting surrounded by TSA [ __ ] his
pants I didn't have any idea that that's
terrifying oh I think I think they knew
you yeah he definitely was playing it
all for sure that kind of sucks though
quite a lot it may have scared the [ __ ]
out of me because I turn around those
dudes just looking at me and like
menacingly and knew my name oh they
absolutely know how much power they have
yeah traveling in an Airport's already
like a really bad experience yeah oh man
traveling to the US it's like there is
no country that is more intimidating to
get into than the US yeah yeah holy I've
never felt like I interrogate you
uh because I was on an Esther and then I
apparently broke some rules that didn't
comply with yesterday that I didn't know
about and apparently that happens
smuggling drugs yeah apparently cocaine
is not allowed no but like I I basically
just broke a very kilos of Coke
yeah I was like oh [ __ ] six is too much
what's the difference yeah that's not
like I I basically long story short is
there's like a lot of very minor rules
about the esta the electronic visa thing
um that is not you know very concisely
written down yeah and I unfortunately
broke one of those rules and the guy was
like well it's all right because you
didn't know about it and this happens
all the [ __ ] time yeah so but but we
have to deport you oh my God and so I
was like oh okay uh well my girlfriend's
already gone through it's not a big deal
it happens all the time yeah does not
get followed up by we have to deport it
that's literally how they phrased it
they were like don't worry man it
happens all the time uh but you have a
choice you can either uh stay in a jail
overnight until we can get your flight
the next day or you can take this other
flight that takes you to Amsterdam
instead and then you have to get a
connecting flight back to Japan what
would you like to do and all I could
hear was like The Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire music just like dude I'm
just like ah
yeah I was like it's like can I find a
friend like so I uh yeah so I was just
like well I'm not [ __ ] staying in a
jail overnight so uh Amsterdam please
every time I go to the Border in America
I feel like a school kid like who's
about getting in trouble you're getting
in trouble yeah and like you go to them
and I feel like a school kid and the
teachers like scolding me it's like why
what are you doing here I'm like oh I'm
sorry I I don't know why but I always
just feel like I needed to to apologize
even if I have all the documentation
even though I'm not doing anything wrong
I just I always feel like sorry
sometimes you just I don't know I mean
like a lot of the times it's been chill
but science you get that one dude you
can tell he just likes it he's just
having a [ __ ]
yeah yeah like you know asking questions
or you're like why would you ask that
question in that way like you're trying
[ __ ] this morning yeah yeah not even I
wish it was there that'd be fun yeah
it's how heavy was it
I don't know dumb [ __ ] it's because all
the Border Police I've met in America
they even if they the most chillest
person in the world all of them have
like all of them are able to project
this Authority in their and their voice
that I've just seen like that that is on
another level compared to like most
other countries I've been to it's it's
like yeah and it's also like it's also I
feel like they have this switch in
Emotion the moment they deem you to be
okay because it's like every time you
walk up it's always like they've got
like some kind of Sourpuss like resting
[ __ ] face you know just like really
mean about it and then the moment they
stamp your thing it's just like oh
you're welcome have a good day have a
good day
thank you thank you when I was a kid
because my mom wasn't the citizen she's
from Sweden yeah okay and so she had a
green card we were coming back from
Mexico and I guess she had left her
green card oh [ __ ] and so we had to
basically sit there and argue with
immigration and they're like well for
300 or whatever it was some stupid fee
that you know years ago would have been
more than what that is now we can do it
for you and figure it out electronically
or
you can go and get your green card and
so basically she stayed at LAX my dad
drove me my sister home and we must have
been like maybe 12. yeah there were like
you know pretty young yeah drop stuff at
home and then drives like you know
probably an hour and a half back to LAX
holy [ __ ] and this is like I remember
probably Landing it was dark outside so
maybe like 10 11 it was super late so he
probably got home at like four in the
morning after dealing with it the whole
like they knew who she was they had
everything there but it was just like in
order to come through without the card
you got to pay like three forms even
though other system they can clearly see
that she has a green card yeah yeah
because it would match up with the
passport that's so [ __ ] so [ __ ] that
shit's annoying just like uh but I've
never had a bad experience yeah with any
any well I mean airport security in any
country uh honestly not really that's
good yeah even either I I it's been
chill I think coming back from Canada is
probably the most aggressively I've
gotten grilled but I was driving oh they
ask you what you're doing there and
whatnot but otherwise I don't think yeah
anyone's super
can't remember damn yeah have you I I
think I've been like interrogated a few
times
um both of both those slimes
that's like a pretty bad I mean we're
both white we're like yeah
this is not looking this is not a great
look my brothers
that's privilege they're like how how
why did you say you were again yeah you
don't look very white yeah so your name
is Joseph okay you're good I see your
name is Gant Manny
I brought some stuff through they really
don't like too like one time we had a
suitcase filled entirely with magic the
Gathering cards
hated
what I don't know I guess it's just too
dense for the x-rays to penetrate and so
it just shows up as like this brick
that way wait okay hold on I gotta know
why are you bringing in a suitcase full
of Magic the Gathering Cuts I don't know
because we didn't use them at all I had
to drag it all the way back home and so
you put it through customs and they're
like hold up what is that what are these
white bricks and then of course like
it's literally filled with cards and
it's like how do you dig through a box
of cards that have been like
meticulously placed yeah for the guys
just you can just see them die on the
inside because you're sitting there
looking at them and they know they're
not gonna be able to put it back
together yeah and so he just sort of
like picks up a couple of them and I
think he gets the vibe that like they
just cause it's just cards uh and so he
let us go but tools they hate tools too
we had to throw I had uh I think we were
in Texas and I had to buy a drill and
some drill bits and
no you can't take a drill you can't take
anything the bits I understand he's like
throw the drill bits away but he
wouldn't let me take a drill and so I'm
gonna tool the battery out yeah so he's
like you have to check it and I'm like
nope throw it in the trash and he's like
he was like confused all right nope
throw it in the trash is there anything
else in my bag you want me to throw in
the trash like if there's anything in my
bag you'd like to throw in the trash
I think he started getting really
uncomfortable because I was just like
basically you know giving him the
authority to throw anything away that he
didn't like right it's like scream screw
you man yeah I just paid 80 bucks for
this drill I don't want to throw it away
oh [ __ ] you assessed the guy yeah I did
oh well I saw them in a way where I gave
him like too much Authority if there's
anything in my bag you want to throw
away do it right now I'm I'm too scared
to session yeah I feel like the moment I
do that I'm getting arrested I wasn't
arguing with him I wasn't saying no
don't take my drill it was just like
anything else you want to throw away no
but it's it's the passive aggressiveness
I could not yeah yeah but I'm not
hindering him
you're an older man than me yeah I think
so I'm just kidding I'm just getting
flashbacks or something that happened
when I was like a [ __ ] teenager
it wasn't actually to do with me but
it's this is probably like one of the
most British stories I've ever seen
happen in the airport so so I was
visiting Spain with some mates and we
were in the south of Spain you know
normal kind of British holiday and so we
are on our way to fly back
and we see that there's another British
guy in front of us that uh has been
basically stopped at the security gate
because in Spain or in yeah in Spain so
because it was found that he had a
bottle of uh a liter bottle of vodka
that obviously you can't take liquids on
the plane he had a liter bottle of vodka
that he tried to pass through security
and so security told him to get rid of
the bottle right and they give him the
bid
and he goes no I'm going to choose the
second option
is he in line he starts [ __ ] chucking
this
and he's like no I refuse to throw this
away [ __ ] you just kick him off the
floor they just kick him off the floor I
don't know because the only reason I
know this because I see this I see him
chugging this ball and everyone that he
goes past he offers a swing too
depending on what mood I was in I
and I'm like this is the most British
thing I've ever seen someone who's just
refusing to throw away this Lea bottle
of vodka and just decides to chug it
before security I definitely think he
could have lingered for a while and
we're like you're forgetting the other
option and like make them say it
you come to tell me to drink it she
looked me in the eyes and tell me that I
am allowed to do it the only weirdest
thing that I've ever had in an airport
on a plane was that um I was on a plane
from Amsterdam to London and as the
plane landed uh there was like an
announcement where they were like Hey so
uh somebody was smoking in the toilet so
we're gonna the police are gonna come on
and take the person off and then yeah
that's gonna be it so literally waiting
two dudes come on go to the back pick
this guy up take him off and it was like
oh I didn't even know what that was
weird it just yeah police came on took
him off I don't know what happens when
you do it I assume they probably are
fine
there's no way they don't detect that
they would 100 if you do anything that
they're gonna know what was this guy
thinking he's like yeah I could just
guide the smoke away from it like it
blew my mind is that that flight is an
hour and 20 minutes you couldn't hold it
it's like that's what I'm saying like
yeah an hour and 20 minutes you can't
hold it or like wait like I I have a
little bit more sympathy for 16 hours
and I'm like you're a complete crippling
at smoking like you're going to
Amsterdam what else are you gonna do
yeah you kind of smoke you can do it
there I just I I didn't understand it
and like I during the flight after I
heard that I was like I did smell smoke
at one point but I just thought I was
crying crazy I thought I was having a
stroke I thought I was like I'm going
crazy yeah because yeah because when you
when you always hear the safety
instructions of like don't smoke in the
toilets because you know it's a it's a
federal offense it's like it's like you
don't have to tell me that no one's
stupid enough to do that there's an
ashtray in the toilet for a reason
people smoke it's probably better than
throwing in the trash yeah you can't
because they want if people are going to
smoke they want them to put it out in
the ashtray yeah as opposed to throwing
it in the trash and lighting it on fire
right because it's literally just
tissues right yeah um so that's the
reason why they have ashtrays on every
plane and I you know it's not true why
do you think there's an ashtray on every
toilet I don't know it's just to keep
people from throwing it in the trash
yeah because if they would have tried
and put it out in the trash dude the
last thing you want is a bigger fire
yeah
so if you're gonna Smoke on the plane at
least for God's sake put it out yeah in
the right way yeah but can we quickly
fact check this yeah I'm telling you
this is why I definitely believe it yeah
because you know they're gonna do
something bad so even the best way to do
it back yeah because I I because like
people are going to break the rules at
least let them break the rules in a safe
way and then punish because I've never
really thought about it but I've always
thought I've always seen the ashtray and
I've always seen people say please don't
smoke on the trail on the plane so I was
like was there an era I wasn't alive
where they were just allowed to smoke on
the planes that's like how I've
rationalized it yeah in my mind yeah
they were you were allowed yeah
that's correct Yeah Yeah by the Federal
Aviation Administration yeah my dad used
to work for Airbus really project
managed putting the wings together and
he told me about it and I was like that
sounds wrong so you see you send smoke
no no no no no no no you can't right
you're not allowed to but if like it's
like but if you do at least there's a
knife it's like a clean needle program
it's like you know they're gonna do
drugs all right so at least do it with a
cleaner a safe way that's why I don't
you know there's a lot of things that
you design where you know people are
going to break the rules there's no way
you can stop it so at least do it so it
doesn't [ __ ] everyone else or anything
so why is that on like a pack of condoms
for anyone who wants to go into my heart
because who if someone gets chlamydia on
the plane there's an effect
you know
and he's gonna die and that doesn't
leave
I think the worst thing I ever saw on a
flight and it's not even that bad was
right as a plane was Landing this woman
who didn't speak English gets up out of
her seat to go use the bathroom and they
started freaking out like I I think they
were like inches away from aborting The
Landing right but they realized that
pretty much no matter what they did was
going to be like the most dangerous
thing for that situation yeah so they
were screaming they're like do not like
leave like stay in the bathroom stay
seated the complete like literally the
planes like coming in for its landing
and someone gets up and goes to the
bathroom
what yeah I don't know I don't think she
I don't know what happened I think I
just got the plan what the [ __ ] yeah I
don't think he'd arrested or fined for
that but I think you can you can get
fined
I'm pretty sure like if you're doing
[ __ ] like that and Landing it's putting
everybody else in danger in yeah because
if they like have to abort or they make
a are you Crossing tens of thousands of
dollars yeah yeah exactly or if they get
someone injured from falling over and
[ __ ] smacking their head on something
yeah yeah it's a liability yeah
[Laughter]
I don't think so
I don't think I've ever seen anything
that crazy on a flight before that's
pretty crazy I'm kind of crazy I
sometimes leave my cell phone signed
along
after they leave before landing I'd put
my seat back
I hate you so much William [ __ ] you I
hate
[Laughter]
people that's the land I put my tray
table down
I closed the window blind
I don't want to see the plane
sometimes I open the ejector the ejector
window
just because I mean we're getting out
anyway
that lends you what like 25 000 fine in
like actual jail time I think it's jail
time that's jail time it depends on the
country okay
hey did your idea is that a tax
write-off you get a fine with the intent
of getting
getting a fine for a video idea is that
a tax rival that I I I don't think so no
idea I have no idea
no one's put that to this test yet
I don't like it why not I shouldn't have
given you that idea actually
I don't know if you're gonna if you get
a DUI and you're filming it is that a
write-off
laws don't exist if you're filming it
right yeah that's that's why oh it's
like I'll be like please
Tick Tock exists right I've always been
interested not personally but it's like
scientifically the whole how much
alcohol can you drink and then drive
yeah thing yeah like because it's based
on the drive or drive legally I drive
legally okay
because obviously it's it's like a
generic they're like yeah you couldn't
drink too yeah that's what they tell
everyone but obviously if you're a
really big guy it's like you can drink a
lot more I always wondered because of
how it works you could easily drink if
you're a giant guy very big yeah before
drinking four beers drive and then you
would still come up as legal to drive
yeah we don't condone any of this
Behavior I know we're saying it's a
hypothetical nor should we nor are we
saying anyone should test it out yeah
it's like the well you mentioned like
the it has been arbitrarily set at yeah
two yeah yeah roughly they think that
that is yeah that's the average right
percentage is what like 0.08 percent I
don't know well in Japan it's zero zero
percent yeah that's like nothing yeah it
feels like kind of actually almost like
false positives would come out of that
maybe I don't know I never thought about
it I I've never driven and had a drink
at any point because like you could have
a drink and then like hours later like
three hours later yeah you should still
have something yeah yeah yeah exactly
like I think like there was a massive
problem where in the UK where people
would go on like an all-night Bender
drive to work the next day and they were
still drunk and still over the limit in
the morning because they drunken so much
than like before all right and late into
the night yeah yeah so you know it's
like your brain says oh I sleep
therefore I'm sleeping it's a really
good way of avoiding that it's just
don't drink absurds amount of alcohol
before work
that's why I like the city though
because it's like you don't have to
think about it here you just get on the
freaking train yeah okay here's the
thing though Japan is it everyone goes
out and gets drunk on weekdays and then
goes to work yeah so yeah well yeah I
think you're just participating in the
culture yeah yeah I'm exactly being an
honorary Japanese
oh my god well I think uh that about
does it for this episode uh do you want
to shout anything out
YouTube channel Tick Tock Turtles shout
out to Turtles all over the world who
are watching show up there you're
awesome have you ever wanted to eat a
giant tortoise I heard they're delicious
I think that I that would that would
feel bad
why do they do that here no no that's
just what happened it's not giant okay
yeah those are like old yeah but they're
really tasty Heaven is a pet
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey look at all these patrons though who
support the show oh my God how do you
guys get so many of them I don't know to
be honest who's your favorite I like
this guy yeah pick a guy I hate this guy
oh yeah wow I changed my mind I like
them okay but this guy over here he's
been causing problems yeah hey if you
like to support the show then head on
over to our patreon patreon.com
trashtaste also follow us on Twitter
means on the subreddit and if you hear
that face listen to us on Spotify and uh
go obviously check out the links in the
description below yeah God you said that
really fast I know I've done it many
episodes now he's the pro if he is like
off for one week I don't know what I
would do I'd be like oh
we literally just say like what does it
just end and then it cuts okay we should
just do that we should just do that
[Music]